interessierte und kritische und der
politische diskurs des parlaments steht
auf dem prüfstand
ich habe viel verständnis für politisch
profilierte positionen aber ich bitte
sie eine im ton der wortwahl und im
respekt miteinander so umzugehen dass es
auch danach gibt uns denken sie bei
eigene entscheidungen an unsere republik
in österreich wie gelangen sie trinke
ich behandlung der schriftlichen anfrage
36 19 da inzwischen einen abgeordneten
sie zugegangen ist erübrigt sich eine
verlesung durch die schriftführer
ich darf den abgeordneten leicht tritt
als ersten frage stelle
zu begründung der anfrage die gemäß § 93
absatz 5 der geschäftsordnung 20 minuten
nicht überschreiten darf
das wort hat ein erpel sie sind an bord
vielen dank herr präsident
geschätzte mitglieder der
bundesregierung geschätzte kolleginnen
kollegen geschätzte damen und herren auf
der tribüne und vor den fernsehschirmen
ob die österreicherinnen und
österreicher nach den szenen die das
ganze land vor eineinhalb wochen gesehen
hat wieder vertrauen in die politik
fassen werden wird von
verantwortungsvollen und
verantwortungsbewussten politikerinnen
und politikern abhängen
die letzten tage haben zur großen
enttäuschung vieler menschen bewiesen
dass die politische führung im land
nicht verantwortungsvoll mit der
schwierigen situation umgeht
die frage die beantwortet werden muss
wer trägt die verantwortung für das
chaos
und welche konsequenzen werden gezogen
fakt ist die regierung kurz ist
gescheitert sebastian kurz obmann der vp
hat die gesamtsituation und der wir uns
jetzt befinden zu verantworten
das aktuelle profil fast folgendermaßen
zusammen
zeit für neues versprach sebastian kurz
und neue zeiten sind in der tat
angebrochen
wenn auch völlig anders als kurz sich da
sich das in seinen düstersten albträumen
hätte ausmalen können
österreich kommt aus dem wunder nicht
heraus was politisch alles möglich ist
türkisblau großspurig von manchen auf
zehn jahre angelegt ist hochkant nach
nur eineinhalb jahren gescheitert profil
sechsundzwanzigster mai 2009 10
ja das türkisblaue experiment ist
gescheitert
kurz hat seine chancen verspielt und
herr bundeskanzler
sie tragen die volle verantwortung
um diese bilanz ist im negativen sinn
wirklich beachtlich in zwei jahren hat
sebastian kurz zwei regierungen
gesprengt um an die macht zu kommen hat
unter anderem zugelassen dass seine
österreichische volkspartei die
wahlkampfkosten um sechs millionen euro
überschritten hat dabei ist vollkommen
unklar wie die övp ihren teuren 2017
wahlkampf über finanziert hat und woher
sebastian kurz diese 13 millionen euro
dafür hatte offengelegt wurden
offensichtlich nur zwei millionen euro
an konzern spenden ich frage wo ist der
rest dieser spenden
wo ist der rest geschätzte damen und
herren und damit so etwas in zukunft
nicht mehr geschehen kann werden wir
heute einen antrag auf deckelung der
wahlkampfspenden einbringen
allein daran scheinen allein der
anschein von bestechlichkeit ist gift
für unsere parlamentarische demokratie
nichts bedeutet
zum video das uns alle bewegt möchte ich
ihnen folgende aussage vorlesen sie
stammt vom gernot blume am 19.5 im
zentrum der auslöser für diese situation
die wir jetzt haben ist das video das
wir alle gesehen haben von dem wir
offensichtlich alle erschüttert waren wo
es um möglichen machtmissbrauch geht um
potenzielle illegale
parteienfinanzierung und andere themen
und es ist ja vollkommen klar dass man
solche vorwürfe dass wenn solche
vorwürfe im raum stehen nicht einfach
zur tagesordnung übergehen kann
auch nicht wenn die direkt betroffenen
personen zurücktreten
da braucht es glaubwürdige lückenlose
aufklärung nachdem das sie nun unseren
gestrigen gesprächen auch nicht in der
form da war war das aus unserer sicht zu
tun was notwendig war
es war notwendig dieses projekt zu
beenden
hier spricht die engste vertrauensperson
von sebastian kurz kanzleramtsminister
prima hier spricht er von illegaler
parteienfinanzierung machtmissbrauch und
anderen spenden an parteien spielen in
diesen sogenannten ibiza vize video eine
große rolle
im video redet strache darüber wie man
mit hilfe von großspendern und
intransparenten vereinenden wahlkampf
gewinnen medien kontrollieren und sich
danach die republik unter den nagel
reißen kann
unsere öffentlichen aufträge für die
staatliche infrastruktur unsere
pressefreiheit ja unsere heimat soll an
russische oligarchen und oligarchen
verscherbelt werden das ist nicht
heimatliebe geschätzte damen und herren
aber nochmals auf das von der övp pd
sagte zurückzukommen
die feuerwehr hält im letzten wahlkampf
millionen an spenden von großkonzernen
und regen sponsoren im gegenzug hört man
sollte die unternehmensbesteuerung um
1,5 milliarden euro gesenkt werden
das hilft genau jenen großkonzernen
steuern zu sparen für ihre gewinne
einzufahren wenn die allgemeinheit die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
nichts davon haben auch durch die
abschaffung der grunderwerbsteuer firma
bilden invest investoren entsteht schon
das ansehen das politik vielleicht
käuflich sein kann
umso erstaunlicher ist die erste
reaktion des bundeskanzlers der
zumindest schon 48 stunden davor über
das video und den inhalt bescheid wusste
den gesamten samstag lang gab es kein
statement
im gegenteil es kamen tausende menschen
auf dem ballhausplatz vor den fernsehern
warteten wahrscheinlich hunderttausende
den ganzen tag vergeblich auf ein
statement des bundeskanzlers das immer
wieder verschoben wurde
schließlich war das erste was die
österreichische bevölkerung nach dem
video vom kanzler zu hören bekam eine
wahlkampfrede
mittlerweile wissen wir dass
bundeskanzler kurz entgegen der meinung
der bürgerinnen und bürger nicht in
neuwahlen gehen wollte
sein ziel weiter an der macht zu bleiben
und die koalition fortzusetzen wenn sich
innenminister herbert kickl damit
abgefunden hätte ein anderes ressort zu
übernehmen
das ist wie wir jetzt wissen die
traurige realität geschätzte damen und
herren
ich möchte
wer jetzt zur frage kommen was sebastian
kurz seit der auflösung der koalition
getan hat und das ist meines erachtens
wirklich essentiell ohne gespräche mit
den vorsitzenden bei anderen
parlamentsparteien zu führen rief der
bundeskanzler einseitig neuwahlen aus in
einem parlamentarischen regierungssystem
wäre es doch eine selbstverständlichkeit
in so einer situation zuerst mit dem
parlament in kontakt zu treten
da muss die frage geklärt werden ob es
für diese regierung weiter fortsetzen
möchte wenn eine minderheitsregierung
machen möchte wenn der übergangskabinett
machen möchte ob es dafür überhaupt eine
mehrheit in diesem haus in diesem
parlament gibt kurz hat sich leider für
einen anderen weg entschieden
märz einen vp finanzminister zum vize
kanzler gemacht er hat expertinnen und
experten ausgewählt und zu den
nachfolgerinnen der fpö ministerinnen
und minister gemacht
zugleich hat kurz seine vw-leute als
deren mitarbeiter in den ministerbüros
installiert und die dialogverweigerung
die diesem prozess die ganze zeit
begleitet hat die wurde fortgesetzt
gleichzeitig hat sich ja kurz ein
maximum an medienpräsenz gesichert ja
das war wohl zweck der ganzen sache bei
den substanzlosen pressekonferenzen im
bundeskanzleramt hatten die anwesenden
journalistinnen und journalisten nicht
einmal die möglichkeit fragen zu stellen
nicht einmal die möglichkeit fragen zu
stellen
das muss man sich einmal versöhnlich
das erste
große interview nach der neuwahl
ankündigung wurde der deutschen bild
zeitung gegeben statt dem orf oder einer
anderen österreichischen zeitungen
stattdessen waren die anstrengungen von
sebastian kurz umso größer wenn es um
mvp wahlwerbung ging bezeichnet und
höchst besorgniserregend
und das setzt sich jetzt bei ihnen hier
vor das merkt man recht gut das abweisen
von schuld und wegreden von jeder
verantwortung geschätzte damen und
herren dass der bundeskanzler in einer
situation noch immer bis zum heutigen
tag kein wort der entschuldigung an die
österreichische bevölkerung richtet hat
mich wirklich erstaunt der bundeskanzler
weil was ist die ist die wichtigste
aufgabe eines bundeskanzlers in einer
derartigen situation in einer derartigen
regierungskrise er muss sich um
parlamentarische mehrheiten kümmern
er muss sein verhältnis zur opposition
verantwortungsbewusst und
verantwortungsvoll gestalten aber es ist
leider nichts überhaupt nichts davon
passiert nachdem die fpö ministerinnen
und minister zurückgetreten sind hat
sich herr kurz nicht und keineswegs um
eine stabile und handlungsfähige
übergangsregierung bemüht für der spd
ist eine parlamentarische mehrheit
braucht er hat sich ausschließlich um
die neue övp alleinregierung bemüht und
das ist es die auf eigene faust
installiert hat die opposition hatte zu
keinem zeitpunkt in die
entscheidungsfindung eingebunden und die
oppositionsführerin und
oppositionsparteien wurden erst nach der
auswahl der ministerium minister für die
schwarz schwarze alleinregierung
informiert die gespräche waren reine
vermutungen ohne verlautbarungen ohne
substanz dass der schwarze
finanzminister vizekanzler werden soll
erfuhr man aus den medien
wir von der sp haben immer eines ganz
klar gesagt wir wollen eine
expertenregierung eine expertenregierung
wo alle regierungsämter von unabhängigen
experten besetzt sind
die für diese schwierige situation
verlässlich die beste lösung sind aber
sie herr kurz der innerhalb von zwei
jahren schon zwei regierungen aufgelöst
hat hat erneut den alleingang gewählt
ohne dialog oder ernsthafte gespräche
verantwortung für unser land zu
übernehmen er kurz das schaut anders aus
in den vergangenen 17 monaten in denen
kurz regierte mussten wir uns für vieles
rechtfertigen
insbesondere bei unseren internationalen
partnern für das parlament und die
österreichische demokratie hat ihre
regierung her kurz seit dezember 2017
nur mehr missachtung und wenig respekt
übrig gehabt gesetze gesetze wurden
durchs parlament gepeitscht und entweder
viel zu kurz oder überhaupt nicht
begutachtet weder von experten noch von
der öffentlichkeit anträge sie erinnern
sich vielleicht wurden absichtlich damit
schneller geht in die falschen
ausschüsse gebracht
sogar ein selbst ermächtigungsgesetz
wurde versucht zum glück ja abgedreht
wurden parlamentarische anfragen eine
kernaufgabe von regierenden werden
dürftig unvollständig und absichtlich
falsch beantwortet sebastian kurz selbst
ist kaum präsent und war bei jeder
zweiten sitzung hier nicht da es gibt
keine diskussion auf augenhöhe
weder im plenum noch in den
parlamentarischen ausschüssen oder
darüber hinaus wenn überhaupt wird die
opposition nur informiert von einbindung
ist keine rede
dabei
auch wenn sie sitz ärgert es ist so
jeder demokrat und jede demokrat in weiß
wie wichtig der gemeinsame dialog ist
der dialog ist für die demokratie
unerlässlich
und man hat das gefühl diese regierung
wie sie hier sitzt mit ausnahme derer
die jetzt dazugekommen sind das kann ich
noch nicht beurteilen will oder versteht
den parlamentarismus nicht geschäfte
damen und herren
[Applaus]
das miteinander der dialog die
kompromissbereitschaft zum wohle aller
dass es ihnen in den letzten 17 monaten
nichts wert gewesen
stattdessen wurde alle alle energie in
den alleingang investiert und darin
heerscharen von politischen akteuren in
allen ministerien zu installieren
es gibt nicht nur die generalsekretäre
es gibt eigene stimme für pr
öffentlichkeitsarbeit unmengen menschen
die dafür bezahlt werden in den
vergangenen 17 monaten wurde durch die
alleingängen die dialogverweigerung das
vertrauen das gegenseitige vertrauen
sehr sehr schwer beschädigt sage ihnen
ganz offen
die letzten tage dieser regierungskrise
haben nicht dazu beigetragen dieses
vertrauen wieder zu erhöhen
ich selbst konnte letzte woche herr
bundeskanzler donnerstag zeuge werden
wie der bundeskanzler gespräche mit der
opposition führt nachdem die hunde
eingelangt war war mit der wichtigere
termin der medientermin das foto als
hauptzweck und das angebot das sie
gemacht haben herr bundeskanzler war ein
reiner gag was kurz hier vorschlägt und
anbietet sind ja
selbstverständlichkeiten
ihr vorschlag der aufklärung der
schweren vorwürfe ja was bietet denn
sonst ist selbstverständlich als das
alles aufzuklären herr kurs ihr
vorschlag dass die opposition bei den
ministerräten sitzen soll ja wenn nichts
mehr beschlossen wird es das eine
unglaublich tolle idee und weil ich
rechtzeitig angekündigt wurde dass ohne
keine gesetze und postenbesetzungen mehr
beschlossen werden sollen fragt sie was
soll das ganze
und die ankündigung ausschüsse nach der
wahl wieder einzusetzen
da kündigen sie etwas an wo dieses
parlament dafür zuständig ist nicht die
bundesregierung
der tour
stattdessen haben sie vorgeschlagen dass
jetzt regierungsinserate auf
informationen über die nationalratswahl
eingeschränkt werden
das heißt im klartext schwarze
regierungsinserate mit dieser schrift
das ist auch nicht das was wir für diese
zeit brauchen geschätzten damen und
herren was
fast 45 millionen euro haben sie letztes
jahr verraten pa ausgegeben
umgelegt auf vier monate bis der
nationalratswahl werden das noch einmal
15 millionen steuergeld ist dass der
plan gewesen meinen vorschlag eine
spenden obergrenze von 10.000 euro
einzuführen
haben sie nicht einmal aufgegriffen was
sie wollen ist dass die övp weiter
spenden ohne limit kassieren kann
und die wahlkampf grenze ohne folgen
überschreiten können aber den anderen
parteien die nicht über großspenden
verfügen denen wollen sie die mittel
kürzen das ist kein dialog er kurz das
ist nur schein und ph meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren
die letzten tage haben ein hässliches
bild unseres schönen landes gezeichnet
ich bin zu 100 prozent beim
bundespräsidenten gesagt hat so sind wir
nicht wovon ich auch zu 100 prozent
überzeugt bin ist das die art und weise
wie hier eine neue vp alleinregierung
installiert wurde nicht in
demokratischen ansprüchen genügt die ich
mir für österreich erwartet
sebastian kurz hat in zwei jahren zwei
regierungen gesprengt werden dessen hat
der soziale errungenschaften zerstört
und den ruf österreichs im ausland
geschädigt sein türkisblaues experiment
geschätzte damen und herren ist krachend
gescheitert
und jetzt versucht hat die svp
herrschaft auszubauen und verzichtet
darauf für eine parlamentarische
mehrheit zu werden diese vorgangsweise
ist verantwortungslos und lässt viele
fragen offen die österreicher und
österreich antworten verfiel
der kurs heute und hier müssen sie das
erste mal fragen zu den ganzen chaos das
sie angerichtet haben beantworten
ich hoffe sie tun das und halten nicht
wieder eine wahlkampfrede in diesem haus
franke schön
zu wort gemeldet der bundeskanzler sehr
geehrter herr präsident sehr geehrte
damen und herren abgeordnete ich bin
normal ein eher ruhiger mensch und ich
habe mir schon viel anhören müssen und
habe schon viel ausgehalten
ich muss zugeben in diesem fall ist es
mir etwas schwer gefallen aber ich habe
mich entschieden mich von ihnen nicht
provozieren zu lassen herr abgehört oder
leicht
ich werde daher auch nicht auf alle
unterstellungen und an platz versuche
reagieren die sie da jetzt schrittweise
aufgelistet haben ich glaube es würde
auch den zeitlichen rahmen sprengen ich
möchte vielmehr die möglichkeit nutzen
ihnen sehr geehrte damen und herren
abgeordnete und natürlich auch den
österreicherinnen und österreichern noch
einmal meine sicht auf die dinge zu
skizzieren und ihnen auch zu beschreiben
warum wir in der letzten woche die
entscheidungen so getroffen haben wie
wir sie getroffen haben ich möchte
vielleicht zunächst einmal mit einem
punkt beginnen wo wir vermutlich
wirklich alle alle fraktionen
übereinstimmen
die vergangene woche das war eine sehr
turbulente zeit für österreich es war
eine herausfordernde zeit für die
republik für die politik in summe und es
hat sicherlich nicht dazu beigetragen
das ansehen österreichs in der welt und
auch das ansehen der politik in
österreich zu steigern
die vergangene woche war wenn wir so
wollen auch eine zäsur in der
politischen arbeit in diesem land ich
möchte daher zu beginn noch einmal
festhalten dass ich sehr sehr stolz und
auch zufrieden bin mit der arbeit die
wir als bundesregierung in den letzten
eineinhalb jahren geleistet haben
ich möchte mich ganz deutlich bei allen
regierungsmitgliedern ganz gleich ob von
volkspartei oder freiheitliche partei
für diese zusammenarbeit bedanken es war
eine zeit in der es uns gelungen ist
nach 60 jahren die schuldenpolitik zu
beenden
in der es uns gelungen ist gegen
illegale migration anzukämpfen
in der sonst gelungen ist
steuerentlastungen durchzuführen den
standort österreich zu attraktivieren
die arbeitslosigkeit zu senken und
endlich wieder das land in die richtige
richtung zu führen
es war eine gute arbeit die hier
geleistet wurde und ich bedanke mich bei
allen mitgliedern der bundesregierung
dafür die enthüllungen der vergangenen
woche haben leider gottes nicht nur dazu
geführt dass eine politische partei
nämlich die fpö sich beschädigt hat sie
haben nicht nur dazu geführt dass das
ansehen österreichs in der welt gelitten
hat sie am nicht nur dazu geführt dass
auch das vertrauen in die politik zurück
gegangen ist sondern die enthüllungen
haben auch dazu geführt dass diese gute
sehr erfolgreiche zusammenarbeit beendet
wurde
ich habe mich daher in den tagen nach
den enthüllungen um eines bemüht nämlich
für stabilität in österreich zu sorgen
ich habe mich bemüht gemeinsam mit dem
bundespräsidenten sicherzustellen dass
wir eine handlungsfähige regierung haben
und vor allem auch dass es zur
aufklärung kommt aller vorwürfe die im
raum stehen und das betrifft zum einen
die inhalte des videos die ideen von
machtmissbrauch von umgang mit
steuergeld und ein falsches
politikverständnis es betrifft aber auch
die art und weise wie dieses video
entstanden ist die frage wer es erstellt
hat und vor allem wer es bezahlt und
beauftragt hat
ich möchte mich an dieser stelle beim
bundespräsidenten bedanken die sie
wissen kommt der bundespräsident nicht
gerade parteipolitisch aus der ecke der
volkspartei aber ich habe in dieser
woche erlebt dass der bundespräsident
sich tag und nacht bemüht hat für
stabilität zu sorgen einen beitrag zu
leisten dass die monate bis zur wahl in
aller ruhe und ordnung über die bühne
gehen können und ich bedanke mich an
dieser stelle explizit für die gute
zusammenarbeit in dieser für uns alle
sehr fordernden phase
nachdem der abgeordnete leichtfried die
ereignisse der letzten woche aus seiner
sicht revue passieren hat lassen möchte
ich noch einmal die möglichkeit nutzen
auch meine sicht der dinge darzulegen
der bundespräsident hat mich am dienstag
beauftragt eine expertenregierung
zusammenzustellen er hat mich gebeten
die freiwerdenden ressorts mit personen
aufzufüllen die über die notwendige
fachkenntnis verfügen aber auch ein
hohes maß an integrität mitbringen und
die unumstritten sind für diese
tätigkeit
ich habe binnen 24 stunden gemeinsam mit
meinem team versucht diese expertinnen
und experten zu finden und ich darf mich
bei den personen die heute hier sitzen
ganz herzlich bedanken dass sie über
nacht bereit waren in dieser schwierigen
situation für die republik
bereitzustehen verantwortung zu
übernehmen ich möchte mich bedanken
ich möchte mich bedanken dass sie bereit
gestanden sind der bitte des
bundespräsidenten und auch meiner zu
folgen alles stehen und liegen zu lassen
teilweise aus anderen bundesländern nach
wien aufzubrechen und bereitzustehen der
republik in dieser heiklen phase zu
dienen
wir haben als übergangsregierung
vergangenen mittwoch bereits die arbeit
aufgenommen 24 stunden nach dem auftrag
des bundespräsidenten hand die erste
ministerratssitzung abgehalten und haben
uns auf drei ziele geeinigt nämlich zum
ersten volle aufklärung aller im raum
stehenden vorwürfe zum zweiten
handlungsfähigkeit der regierung in
österreich zur fortsetzung der
amtsgeschäfte bis zu den wahlen aber
auch internationale und europäische
handlungsfähigkeit in einer für
österreich und europa nicht und
entscheidenden phase und wir haben uns
zum dritten dazu entschieden die
oppositionsparteien einzuladen in den
ministerrat sitzungen teilzunehmen und
auch ein maximum an transparenz und
einbindung sicherzustellen
ich möchte auch gerne festhalten dass
ich in den vergangenen tagen auch wenn
das teilweise anders medial kolportiert
wurde nicht nur mit dem
bundespräsidenten sondern auch mit allen
parteichefs mehrere persönliche und auch
telefonische gespräche geführt habe
ich möchte mich explizit bei den neos
bedanken für die konstruktive
herangehensweise es war nicht immer
es war nicht immer so
es war nicht immer so dass wir einer
meinung waren wir sind es auch heute
nicht weder in inhaltlichen fragen noch
in fragen der vorgehensweise aber die
neos waren trotzdem die einzige partei
die mir ganz klare wünsche und
anregungen mit gegeben hat wie sie sich
erwarten würden dass diese
übergangsregierung agiert ich möchte
darüber hinaus festhalten und das
erscheint mir durchaus wichtig dass ich
bis heute keine einzige kritische stimme
zu den ausgewählten experten gehört habe
ich habe niemanden gehört der die
auswahl dieser expertinnen und experten
die parteipolitisch sehr
unterschiedliche hintergründe haben die
alle fachlich qualifiziert sind und die
alle integer sind gehört habe im
gegenteil landeshauptmann das kurziel
ein hochrangiger vertreter der
sozialdemokratie hat sogar öffentlich in
interviews festgehalten dass es bei
diesem misstrauensvotum eigentlich um
ganz etwas anderes geht ich zitiere er
hat wörtlich gesagt es geht hier um
parteiinterner man könne schlicht und
ergreifend jetzt nicht mehr zurück und
sehr geehrte damen und herren
abgeordnete lassen sie mich abschließend
noch einen punkt festhalten der mich
wirklich verblüfft ich verstehe ja in
all der aufgeheizten stimmung die
rachegelüste mancher den wunsch sich
vielleicht für die wahl in eine bessere
position zu bringen
auch die idee parteiinterner sprechen zu
lassen und nicht das wohl des staates im
blick zu haben
aber was ich wirklich nicht verstehe ist
dass die reaktion auf das gestrige
wahlergebnis ist dass der
misstrauensantrag gegen meine person
jetzt auf die ganze regierung ausgedehnt
wird
vor wenigen tagen war noch das ziel mich
als bundeskanzler abzuwählen und
vielleicht als taktik durchaus
verständlich aber jetzt auch noch die
ganze regierung stürzen zu wollen wenige
monate vor einer wahl das ist etwas das
kann glaube ich niemand in diesem land
nachvollziehen
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich bleibe
bei meiner haltung ich glaube was
wichtig ist ist eine handlungsfähige
regierung in österreich auf europäischer
ebene und international aufklärung aller
vorwürfe die im raum stehen und eine
parteiübergreifende zusammenarbeit
ich möchte heute gerne das versprechen
abgeben dass ich ganz gleich in welcher
funktion meinen beitrag dazu leisten
werde
für stabilität in österreich zu sorgen
und sollte dieses votum heute so
ausgehen wie ich es erwarte dann werden
wir der nächsten regierung ganz gleich
wie sie aussehen wird sicherlich keine
steine in den weg legen sondern sie
bestmöglich unterstützen
ich glaube
dass die wählerinnen und wähler gott sei
dank das recht haben am wahltag eine
entscheidung zu treffen bis dahin
allerdings ist das parlament am wort wir
haben uns bemüht seitens der
bundesregierung und auch ich persönlich
habe mich bemüht
in der letzten woche meinen beitrag zur
stabilität zu leisten
wir haben uns bemüht eine
handlungsfähige regierung auf die beine
zu stellen die die amtsgeschäfte in
aller ruhe bis zur wahl verwalten kann
die uns in europa und international
vertreten kann und die bereit ist diese
aufgabe auch wahrzunehmen
im september ist die bevölkerung am wort
bis dahin ist allerdings die
verantwortung eine entscheidung zu
treffen im parlament und ich bin
überzeugt davon
sie werden das auch tun vielen dank
nachdem wir noch einige fragen
schriftlich zugegangen sind darf ich
auch noch die gestellten fragen
beantworten bzw verlesen ich darf
aufgrund der zeitknappheit vielleicht
die fragen zusammenfassen zu den fragen
1 bis 15 22 und 23 so wie wohl die
meisten von ihnen habe ich am
freitagabend um 18 uhr erstmals das
besagte video gesehen
der vize kanzler hat mich bereits am
abend davor darüber informiert dass eine
mögliche negative berichterstattung über
ihn im raum steht aufgrund von bild und
tonaufnahmen über details konnte er mich
damals aber auch noch nicht informieren
die inhalte des videos und die reaktion
der freiheitlichen partei haben uns sehr
erschüttert und gezeigt dass es hier
einen anderen zugang zur politik gibt
das video und auch der umgang der fpö
damit haben darüber hinaus dem ansehen
unseres landes geschadet vor diesem
hintergrund war für mich klar dass das
das ende der koalition bedeutet nach dem
erscheinen des videos bin ich mit dem
bundespräsidenten in kontakt getreten
die über die inhalte sich auch sehr
schockiert gezeigt hat seitdem stehe ich
mit dem bundespräsidenten
selbstverständlich in laufendem kontakt
zu den fragen 6 und 7
wie gesagt ich habe das video das erste
mal gesehen als es am freitag um 18 uhr
online gestellt wurde
seither sind diese inhalte sowohl der
öffentlichkeit als auch den
ermittlungsbehörden gleichermaßen
zugänglich
zu den fragen 8 und 9 ein auskunftsrecht
des bundeskanzlers gegenüber den
genannten behörden gibt es nicht im
regierungsprogramm war die einführung
entsprechender berichtspflichten an
bundeskanzler und vizekanzler vorgesehen
eine umsetzung war für die kommenden
monate bis zum sommer geplant zu den
fragen 11 bis 17 mein ziel ist es in
dieser phase alles zu tun um stabilität
in österreich sicherzustellen und auch
zu gewährleisten dass die amtsgeschäfte
in einer sos fortgeführt werden können
das ist laut verfassung meine aufgabe
als bundeskanzler und das ist auch das
womit mich der bundespräsident betraut
hat der bundespräsident hat
den auftrag gegeben eine handlungsfähige
übergangsregierung auf die beine zu
stellen
das habe ich versucht innerhalb von 24
stunden zustande zu bringen
auch die vertreter der im parlament
vertretenen fraktionen und die
landeshauptleute habe ich zu gesprächen
getroffen
ich habe sowohl persönlich mit ihnen
gespräche geführt als auch sie
telefonisch am laufenden gehalten
zur frage 18 nach bekanntgabe von
neuwahlen wird sich die neue volkspartei
selbstverständlich für diese wahl
entsprechend vorbereiten
bis jetzt sind aber keine plakatflächen
reserviert zur frage 19
die mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter der
kabinette pflegen einen sorgsamen umgang
mit informationen und vor allem den
akten
dazu sind sie verpflichtet bestehende
kabinetts akte werden nach ausscheiden
eines regierungsmitglied dem
österreichischen staatsarchiv übergeben
zur frage 20 und 24
ermittlungstätigkeiten zu strafrechtlich
relevanten vorwürfe obliegen der
exekutive und der justiz ich setze mein
vertrauen in unseren rechtsstaat und
habe die zuständigen bundesminister
sucht alle notwendigen ressourcen zur
verfügung zu stellen um eine unabhängige
aufklärung sicherzustellen
zur frage 21 die neue volkspartei hält
sich selbstverständlich an alle
geltenden gesetzlichen regelungen in
diesem zusammenhang aufwendungen werden
gemäß parteiengesetz und allfälliger
sonstige verpflichtungen auch
entsprechend gemeldet zur frage 25 der
bundespräsident und ich haben uns
bestmöglich bemüht alles in unserer
macht stehende zu tun um stabilität zu
gewährleisten und die neuen minister
bestmöglich organisatorisch zu
unterstützen
als oberste organe sind sie natürlich
letztverantwortlich und sind auch für
personalentscheidungen in ihren ressorts
und vor allem auch in ihren kabinetten
selbstverantwortlich vielen dank
schluss
zu wort gemeldet die abgeordnete
klubobfrau ein gedanke vielen dank herr
präsident zögert die bundesregierung wo
es haus und sehr geehrte damen und
herren
herr bundeskanzler sie haben jetzt sehr
viel gesagt aber sie haben noch nicht
gesagt dass ihre bundesregierung
gescheitert ist und sie wissen dass sie
als bundeskanzler allein verantwortlich
dafür sind wie die auswahl
viele ihrer minister und ihres
koalitionspartners aussieht und es war
trotz aller warnungen der fall dass sie
diese koalition eingegangen sind und sie
tragen aus unserer sicht somit auch die
verantwortung für das scheitern ihrer
koalitionsregierung und die
verantwortung für die derzeitige
situation
ihre politik ihre politik stößt
österreich stößt dieses land jetzt zum
zweiten mal in neuwahlen weil sie nicht
bekommen haben was sie wollten
sie hätten diese koalition nämlich
einfach weitergeführt das haben sie
jetzt auch nicht gesagt nämlich dann
wenn sie ein ministerium mehr dafür
bekommen hätten das innenministerium
und jetzt nachdem und jetzt nachdem hier
scheitern scheitern
herr bundeskanzler offensichtlich
geworden ist fordern sie von uns
abgeordneten des nationalrates
stabilität sein
ja sie wollen zustimmung für eine
regierung die keine parlamentarische
mehrheit hat und ländern wir es beim
namen
nennen wir es beim namen sie wollen
zustimmung und vertrauen für eine vp
alleinregierung und zwar im nachhinein
im nachhinein denn sie haben selbst im
moment des scheiterns ihrer eigenen
bundesregierung ist nicht der mühe wert
gefunden mit der opposition dieses
hauses zur bildung einer
übergangssituation den dialog zu suchen
und um eine stabile unterstützung zu
werben
nein ihr handeln hat nichts mit
verantwortung zu tun
ihre vorteile
ihre vorgangsweise ist einzigartig in
der geschichte der zweiten republik
es ist ein
es ist ein harmloser es ist ein
zügelloser und verantwortungsvoller
griff nach macht den wechsel
aber die macht in unserem land herr
bundeskanzler geht vom volke aus und von
den menschen und nicht von ihm
[Applaus]
meine damen hatte ich bitte sie bei
aller emotion
ich würde sie bitten der würde des
hauses zu entsprechen und zuzuhören
ich verstehe dass cvp etwas nervös ist
an dem heutigen tag aber ich sage ihnen
es ist ungeheuerlich
es ist ungeheuerlich in einer solchen
situation die ein präsident von der
geschichte der zweiten republik ist
zustimmung und vertrauen einzufordern
was nur ihren eigenen wünschen
entspricht
wir wir
wir abgeordnete des parlaments sind den
menschen verpflichtet die uns gewählt
haben und nicht
und nicht den persönlichen interessen
eines einzelnen die situation in die
sich als bundeskanzler sie sich befinden
ist keine alltägliche und man kann
verstehen dass es keine einfache ist
gerade in solchen situationen zeigt sich
jedoch wahre führungsstärke und anstatt
das verbindende vor das trennende zu
stellen
die unterstützung der abgeordneten
dieses hauses zu suchen haben sie sich
entschlossen den weg alleine zu gehen
und somit den weg der stabilität die
unser land die die menschen in
österreich zu dringend bräuchten zu
verlassen
es ist vollkommen gleichgültig wer die
bundesregierung bildet ist es für sie
vollkommen nebensächlich vorher
abzuklären ob diese ihre vorgeschlagene
regierung eine mehrheit im nationalrat
hat sie herr bundeskanzler gehen davon
aus dass es die pflicht von uns
abgeordneten ist ihr handeln im
nachhinein zu rechtfertigen
das hat nichts mit demokratische haltung
zu tun
der österreicherinnen und österreicher
haben sich von ihnen
verantwortungsvolles handeln gewünscht
und erwartet und diese erwartung haben
sie nicht erfüllt es ist die aufgabe des
bundeskanzlers die stabilität
insbesondere in krisenzeiten zu bewahren
und zu fördern und diese aufgabe sind
sie nicht gerecht geworden
wer vertrauen wie muss verantwortung
leben sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler
das gilt in jeder lebenssituation und
insbesondere gilt das für eine
bundesregierung und ein staatsamt wie
iris was heißt verantwortung
aus unserer sicht heißt verantwortung
die mit einem staat samt verbunden ist
ein würdiger repräsentant dieses staates
zu sein und es bedeutet das gemeinwohl
die allgemeinheit im blick zu haben es
bedeutet auch einen weg einzuhalten der
von respekt der von kooperation und der
von dialogbereitschaft getragen ist der
bundeskanzler hingegen appellieren an
verantwortung und meinen sich selbst sie
stellen dass ich vor dass wir
verantwortung heißt nicht aus dem
staatsamt heraus wahlkampf zu führen
staatsämter sind keine wahlkampfbüros
und verantwortung heißt ihren vor ein
paar tagen bestellten ministern ihrer
regierung keine aufpasser in die
kabinette zu setzen
ja staatsämter verpflichten dazu nicht
den eigenen vorteil in den vordergrund
zu stellen und sie war pflicht noch dazu
das gemeinwohl die res publica das
interesse des landes der menschen vor
alles andere zu stellen und das bedeutet
respektvoll miteinander umzugehen es
bedeutet dass man weiß dass kooperation
dialog grundvoraussetzung und basis sind
für vertrauen und vertrauen
und vertrauen wiederum ist voraussetzung
für eine mehrheit im parlament sehr
geehrte damen und herren und herr
bundeskanzler
sie wollen nicht überzeugen sie wollen
erzwingen aber vertrauen kann man nicht
erzwingen vertrauen muss man sich
erwerben man muss hart dafür arbeiten
und es ist mit der würde des staatsamtes
eines bundeskanzlers unvereinbar den
dialog mit abgeordneten zu vermeiden
verantwortung bedeutet auch sein eigenes
scheitern zu erkennen und zu geben
ein verantwortungsvoller umgang heißt
nur ein verantwortungsvoller umgang mit
seinem staatsamt bildet vertrauen ein
verantwortungsloser umgang mit dem
staatsamt bildet den boden für
misstrauen
herr bundeskanzler sieht unsere helfer
der regierung genießen das vertrauen des
sozialdemokratischen abgeordneten nicht
ich stelle hat daher den
misstrauensantrag gemäß paragraph 55 der
geschäftsordnung des nationalrats
abgeordneten rendi-wagner kolleginnen
und kollegen betreffend versagen des
vertrauens gegenüber der bundesregierung
der nationalrat wolle beschließen der
bundesregierung und der staatssekretärin
wird gemäss artikel 74 absatz 1 b vg in
verbindung mit 78 absatz 2 bvg durch
ausdrückliche entschließung des
nationalrats das vertrauen entsagt
dankeschön
der
der antrag ist ausreichend unterstützt
und steht somit den verhandlungen und
ordnungsgemäß eingebracht zum wort
gemeldet ist der klubobmann bürger sehr
geehrter herr präsident
herr bundeskanzler gesetzte mitglieder
der bundesregierung meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren liebe zuseherinnen und
zuseher
es ist eigentlich unfassbar und
unglaublich wie die spd heute hier ihre
dringliche anfrage begründet um soeben
einen misstrauensantrag einbringt gegen
die gesamte bundesregierung meine damen
und herren die sozialdemokratische
partei handelt hier gegen das volk und
auch gegen den willen unseres
bundespräsidenten es ist einfach
unfassbar
bundeskanzler bastian kurz hat seit dem
bekanntwerden des ibiza videos und auch
den rücktritten in der fpö umsichtig und
verantwortungsvoll gehandelt
er hat gezeigt dass er dieses land auch
in einer schwierigen situation gut
leiten kann und in absprache mit den
herrn bundespräsidenten letzten endes
diese bundesregierung auch mit absolut
und expertinnen und experten sozusagen
ergänzt und ich möchte eines noch
festhalten dass wir im september
neuwahlen haben das war kein wunsch
sondern das war eine notwendigkeit wird
nennen wir diese bilder gesehen hat was
dort vorgefallen ist dann kann man das
sagen so kann man nicht zur tagesordnung
übergehen meine damen und herren
und eines muss auch klar sein dass
gerade das innenministerium hier mit
einem unabhängigen experten besetzt
werden muss das ist für den
bundeskanzler ganz klar gewesen und das
ist auch für die österreicherinnen und
österreicher klar wir wollen hier volle
transparenz volle aufklärung und daher
kann es nicht sein dass ein ehemaliger
fpö generalsekretär weiterhin
innenministerium sitzt das muss mit
einem unabhängigen experten so wie es
jetzt der fall ist besetzt werden
ja es ist bedauerlich dass diese sehr
gute zusammenarbeit so zu ende gehen
muss weil wir viel weitergebracht haben
und als klubobmann und die gesamte
volkspartei ist auf diese zeit auch
stolz weil und das sagen auch die
menschen draußen es ist selten zuvor so
viel weitergebracht werden im positiven
sinne und die menschen anerkennen und
respektieren das aber es ist notwendig
letzten endes in diese neuwahlen zu
gehen damit die bürgerinnen und bürger
letzten endes auch nach diesen
skandalösen vorfällen die entscheidung
treffen kann wie es in österreich auch
weitergehen soll und ich möchte an
dieser stelle weil das ist schon auch
ein einzigartiger historischer
augenblick den wir heute hier leider
miterleben müssen ich möchte den herrn
bundespräsidenten van tabellen noch
einmal zitieren was er bei seiner
ansprache an alle österreicherinnen und
österreicher auf festgehalten hat gesagt
ich appelliere an alle
verantwortungsträger in diesem land die
politische verantwortung auch für dieses
land zu tragen
denken sie bitte jetzt nicht daran was
für ihre partei was sie für ihre partei
kurzfristig herausholen können sondern
denken sie daran was sie für österreich
tun können fragen sie nicht sagt er
weiter
hilft es mir bei der wahl sondern fragen
sie hilft es österreich hilft es uns im
inneren stärkstes unsere glaubwürdigkeit
in der welt zitat ende
das hat der bundespräsident gesagt und
das sind eindeutige worte für diese
bundesregierung
meine damen und herren österreich
braucht jetzt stabilität das ist auch
das was die menschen in unserem land in
unserem land zu recht verlangen
rot blau macht heute genau das gegenteil
und stürzt das land ins chaos
wenn sie heute den bundeskanzler oder
gar die gesamte bundesregierung abwählen
dann haben sie auch die verantwortung
dafür zu tragen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren von
esprit und es versteht absolut niemand
wenn rund drei monate vor einer wahl
eine handlungsfähige bundesregierung die
vom bundespräsidenten nach eingesetzt
wurde abgewählt wird es verstehen auch
ihre eigenen wählerinnen und wähler
nicht
und gestern bei der eu wahl hat die
bevölkerung ganz klar den kurs von
sebastian kurz und damit den kurs einer
politischen mitte unterstützt und
gestärkt meine damen und herren und wir
danken auch den wählerinnen und wählern
dafür
und die aktuellen umfragen zeigen auch
ganz genau was die bevölkerung auch will
zwei drittel der menschen wollen dass
sebastian kurz bis zur nationalratswahl
bundeskanzler frei 65 prozent sind gegen
einen misstrauensantrag und fast drei
viertel nämlich 73 prozent befürworten
diese bundesregierung um die stabilität
im land aufrecht schalten
meine damen und herren jetzt wirklich
jeder etwas muss nicht gestern erlebt
habe war ballbesitz in meiner kleinen
800 einwohner gemeinde sicherten
erstkommunion oder haben sich herum
geduld am ortsplatz wahllokal kirche
gemeindeamt ist nicht weit auseinander
und ich bin auf den platz gegangen und
hat mit den menschen gesprochen
man kann sie es war ne va plus
nachbargemeinden da es geht natürlich
nur um das einzige thema was ist jetzt
mit der regierung wie geht das morgen
sozusagen aus war gestern das thema ich
habe keinen einzigen menschen getroffen
keine frau und keinen mann und ich habe
mit sehr vielen geredet weil sie auch
auf mich zugekommen sind und dass worden
mit 0 55 prozent bei mir daheim aber es
seien nicht nur fehler und alle haben
gesagt wir sollen appellieren an die
mandatsträger von s p & f b das kann es
doch nicht sein dass heute diese
bundesregierung abgewählt wird alle es
war unisono
man findet niemanden in der bevölkerung
der das passiert meine damen und herren
wut und emotion sind schlechte ratgeber
in einer solchen zeit und das hat auch
daniela kittner vor wenigen tagen im
kurier geschrieben und ich kann hier nur
voll zustimmen weil sie sagt zum einen
es gibt keinen inhaltlichen anlass dafür
den bundeskanzler das misstrauen
auszusprechen
aufgrund ereignisse rund um das edition
video war diese regierungskoalition mit
der fpö nicht mehr fortsetzen sagt sie
zum zweiten sagt sie stehen in den
kommenden wochen zahlreiche
weichenstellungen für die europapolitik
der kommenden fünf jahre an wer aus der
bundeskanzler sebastian kurz kann unser
land hier den glaubwürdig vertreten er
ist politisch legitimiert bezog genießt
international hohe anerkennung und
verfügt über in standing dass kein noch
so hoch qualifizierter beamte haben
könnte
das schreibt daniela kittner im kurier
meine damen und herren wir sollten es
lesen
und christen streetdance das argument
der sp ein reines expertenkabinett würde
für mehr stabilität sorgen ist
lächerlich und ohne jedes argument hier
geht es um wahltaktik zum schaden
österreichs und genau das ist es was sie
hier gerade geboten haben wenn sie von
der grunderwerbsteuer und von
steuerfragen reden und damit die
dringliche anfrage und den um den antrag
begründen dass sie jetzt in einigen
stunden diese bundesregierung abwählen
ich kann ihnen nur eines sagen und sie
habe sagt von kollegen rendi-wagner die
macht geht vom volke aus
das volk hat gestern bewiesen wie das
volk entscheidet und sie werden es sehen
das volk wird auch im september so
entschieden weil das die bevölkerung
nicht mit dreck ich bedanke mich
bedanken ich bedanke mich bei dieser
bundesregierung
es ist heute ein tag den sich dieses
wunderbare land nicht verdient hat meine
damen und herren ich danke dieser
bundesregierung ich appelliere an ihre
vernunft an ihr staatspolitisches
verhalten und nicht die partei
interessen in den vordergrund zu stellen
sondern unsere wunderschöne republik
österreich das sind da sind sie
verpflichtet dazu meine damen und herren
zu wort gemeldet kuban kickl
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren hohes haus
liebe so sehr die sie die debatte an den
bildschirmen zu hause verfolgen das sind
keinesfalls einfache stunden sind
keinesfalls alltägliche stunden die
unser land seit dem 18
mai dieses jahres durchlebt vieles ist
undurchsichtig vieles ist verworren
vieles ist unklar
und ich denke umso wichtiger ist dass
klarheit zu schaffen
zusammenhänge aufzuzeigen hintergründe
herzustellen aufzuklären wie es der herr
bundeskanzler heute gesagt hat und damit
die basis für weichenstellungen zu haben
die für zwei dinge in diesem land sollen
für stabilität aber auch für sauberkeit
für stabilität und für sauberkeit meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren eine
solche vorgangsweise nenne ich
verantwortungsbewusst
das ist die staatspolitische
verantwortung die in diesen stunden
gefragt ist das ist die staatsraison von
der so viel die rede ist und wir
freiheitliche nehmen diese verpflichtung
zur staatsraison genauso ernst und wir
nehmen sich genau so war wie wir die
tätigkeit in unseren einzelnen ressorts
im zuge dieser bundesregierung von der
ersten bis zur letzten minute war und
ernst genommen haben ich habe ihre
aussagen sehr genau verfolgt herr
bundeskanzler sie sagen dass die arbeit
gut gewesen ist und notwendig für das
land da gebe ich ihnen recht
sie sagen dass es ihnen leid tut dass
diese koalition zerbrochen ist
da glaube ich eher dass es ihnen leid
tut dass ihre macht strategie nicht
aufgegangen ist und sie sagen dass die
freiheitliche partei sich nicht nur
selbst geschadet sondern mit dem video
und den enthüllungen die ganze
regierungsarbeit zerstört und beendet
hat und hier ist die wahrheit definitiv
eine andere wir und da spreche ich für
die freiheitlichen regierungsmitglieder
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren wir
haben jeden tag unsere regierungsarbeit
mit voller leidenschaft mit allem
einsatz und sie spreche auch für mich
persönlich mit einem großen
rot-weiß-roten mit einem patriotischen
herz gearbeitet gegen viele widerstände
und anfeindungen die es gegeben hat und
ich stehe auch nicht an zu sagen wir
haben sehr gut mit den kolleginnen und
kollegen der volkspartei
zusammengearbeitet auf regierungsebene
und auch auf der ebene des parlaments
dankeschön dafür
auf augenhöhe ich möchte fast schon von
einer freundschaftlichen basis sprechen
haben wir gerade auch mit dem
bundeskanzler zusammengearbeitet und ich
möchte sogar so weit gehen dass unser
vertrauen in den bundeskanzler in
wahrheit auch das ideelle fundament
dieses neuen regierens gewesen ist
wir haben selbstverständlich keine
sekunde gezögert nach dem erscheinen
diese skandal videos die entsprechenden
konsequenzen zu ziehen
das ist eine selbstverständlichkeit und
jedem von uns war unmittelbar klar dass
es personelle konsequenzen braucht und
dass es inhaltliche konsequenzen braucht
und jene die diese bürger betroffen
haben die haben genauso wie wir
vertrauensvoll mit dem bundeskanzler
auch vereinbart haben sich entsprechend
zurückgezogen sie haben genau das
gefahren was wir in einem
vertrauensverhältnis miteinander
vereinbart haben und genau so haben wir
freundschaftlich und vertrauensvoll den
weg weiter definiert dass wir norbert
hofer vorschlagen werden um die rolle
des vize kanzlers zu übernehmen und dass
wir ein inhaltliches paket auf den weg
bringen werden um all die vorwürfe
abzuarbeiten und die es auch in diesem
video geht
wir haben unseren teil der vereinbarung
gehalten und wir haben darauf vertraut
der bundeskanzler dass auch sie in ihren
einheiten in diesen nicht leichten
stunden haben wir ein ganz anderes
gesicht des herrn bundeskanzlers erlebt
als dasjenige das wir ihm erkennen
dieses freundliche und ewig lächelnde er
hat ein anderes gesicht gezeigt er hat
die ganze eu für das fehlverhalten von
zwei personen die die konsequenzen
gezogen haben so wie wir es uns
vereinbart haben
in sippenhaft genommen das hat er getan
er hat versucht eine schwierige phase
eines regierungspartners auszunützen er
hat versucht den eigenen machtbereich zu
erweitern das war die reaktion des
bundeskanzlers in diesen stunden
es ging ihm
und seinen beratern nur darum das
innenministerium in den griff zu
bekommen
denn herr bundeskanzler ich habe mit
ibiza und mit russischen oligarchen
vielleicht weniger zu tun als andere die
hier auf diesen regierungsbänken sitzen
ich habe gar keinen sinn zu sagen
es klingt etwas ganz ganz anderes es
ging um die wiederherstellung der wahren
macht achse der alten vw meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren und diese
achse besteht aus zwei ressorts
das eine ist das justizressort das
befindet sich in schwarzen hemden
das zweite ist das innenressort da habe
es ein problem gegeben und dieses lag
musste geschlossen werden und in einer
hauruck-aktion wo sie den
bundespräsidenten wahrscheinlich
genommen haben um salopp formuliert zu
haben sie haben sie eine situation
herbeigeführt wo beide diese ressorts in
den händen der segen partei sind und
damit genau das gemacht was der
bundespräsident ausschließen wollte bei
der regierungsbildung jetzt haben sie es
wieder fest in ihren händen
und das können wir uns fragen warum ist
das so und ich gehe davon aus meine
damen und herren dass wir in den
kommenden wochen und in den kommenden
monaten vielleicht dinge erfahren werden
ja vielleicht auch ein sittenbild zum
vorschein kommen wird in dem
zusammenhängen wo ich ihnen nur sagen
kann dass vielleicht das was wir auf den
bändern von ibi zu sehen diese dinge die
alle unter alkoholeinfluss gesprochen
wurden gegen die wirklichkeit die
nüchtern ist verblassen könnten und der
bundeskasse
sie reden in einer generösen arzt über
ermittlungen das zeigt er hier
selbstverständnis ich weiß nicht ich war
immer der meinung dass die justiz von
sich selbst außer mit sie haben sich
hier so hingestellt und so getan als ob
sie irgendetwas freizugeben hätten in
richtung ermittlungen und jetzt gibt es
einen zaghaften ansatz nach dem tage
verstrichen sind in dem alles beseitigt
werden konnte was zu beseitigen gewesen
ist
der bundeskanzler sie sind wer
bundeskanzler sie sind getrieben worden
sie sind getrieben worden von jener
alten eferding von der sie den menschen
im letzten wahlkampf versprochen haben
dass ich sie überwunden haben dass sie
hinter sich gelassen haben und dass sie
sie kontrollieren mit ihrer groß
inszenierten generalvollmacht nichts
davon ist wahr
meine stärken
35 freiheit kann man nur denjenigen der
sich treiben lässt und sebastian kurz
hat sich treiben gelassen
sie sind am scheideweg gestanden da das
regierungsprojekt dass ihnen angeblich
wichtig und teuer gewesen ist dort die
machtinteressen insbesondere der vp
niederösterreich wo ich mich frage wo
die große problematik liegt wenn andere
politische kräfte als jener die aus
niederösterreich kommen in diesen innen
ressort vielleicht einmal einen einblick
nehmen diese frage halte ich für
unglaublich spannend und für unglaublich
aufklärungs wert
die freiheitlichen wir haben uns für das
regieren entschieden wir haben uns für
die weitere arbeit im interesse der
bevölkerung entschieden weil wir wissen
dass die menschen diese regierungsarbeit
geschätzt haben und dass niemand diese
neuwahlen will weise nur geld kosten und
in wahrheit notwendig sind sie haben
sich für was anderes entschieden sie
haben sich getrieben von anderen herr
bundeskanzler
ich weiß nicht ob ich ihnen das
zugutehalten soll oder ob ich ihnen das
vorwerfen soll
beides kann man tun beides wäre zulässig
aber sie haben in diesen stunden nach
der macht gegriffen inklusive der
möglichkeiten des verschleiern des
verhinderns und möglicherweise auch des
zu decken
im interesse der alten fab nicht im
interesse der österreichischen
bevölkerung und
unter bundeskanzler uns herr
bundeskanzler
sie haben gedacht die freiheitliche
partei wird einknicken
sie haben gedacht dieses spiel wird
aufgehen und wir lassen uns mit
irgendetwas abspeisen damit sie weiter
machen können und dieses problem
erledigt haben
da haben sie uns unterschätzt da haben
sie uns wirklich unterschätzt denn wir
sind angetreten bei diesem
regierungsprojekt um genau diese alte
form der politik zu überwinden die sie
jetzt wieder beleben niederösterreich
hat das kommando übernommen
es ist ein mehrfacher vertreter den
schlusssatz dies dann meerwasser
vertrauensbruch denn wir hier erleben
und her bundeskanzler ich verwende jetzt
ihre eigene sektion dieser griff nach
der macht ist widerlich
das geht sich für uns nicht mehr aus und
auch darüber werden die wählerinnen und
wähler im september entscheiden
so wird
zu wort gemeldet
sehr geehrter herr präsident werte
mitglieder der bundesregierung sagte der
bundeskanzler werte kolleginnen kollegen
werde zuschauer diesel weniger emotion
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
sachlichkeit und kühlen kopf jetzt es
ist zweifelsohne die turbulenteste zeit
da ist schon in der politik die nicht
nur ich sondern wahrscheinlich alle
erlebt haben und es ist höchst
bedauerlich welches bild wir abgeben als
österreich im ausland aber auch als
politik gegenüber den menschen die
verunsicherung und fahren der
vertrauensverlust der einhergegangen ist
vor allem natürlich mit den bildern in
dem video das wir gesehen haben bei den
menschen ist sehr sehr schwer wieder gut
zu machen und wir alle miteinander haben
sorge dafür zu tragen dass wir beweisen
und sicherstellen dass klar ist dass wir
nicht so sind das mit den populisten
kein staat zu machen ist davor haben wir
gewarnt dass die nähe der fpö zu
russland auch dubiose beziehungen
beinhaltet auch nach vorhaben wir
gewarnt
wir haben noch am tag vor der
veröffentlichung des videos gefragt an
sie herr bundeskanzler in österreich
über die nötig scharfen
parteienfinanzierungsgesetz verfügt dass
wir ausschließen können dass über
dubiose kanäle über möglicherweise
illegale kanäle parteien finanziert
werden
und sie haben das abgeschafft wird
gemeint wir sind eines der
transparentesten länder und recht haben
wir gehabt und wissen sie was ich
bedauere dass wir recht gehabt haben wir
echt weg gehabt haben das haben wir ein
video gesehen hier ist eine partei die
bereit ist für den griff zur macht die
interessen österreichs die schätze
österreichs das wasser zu verraten und
zu verkaufen für macht für einfluss
und für hier das ist eine besondere
kategorie die wir gesehen haben für die
ich mich sehr schäme aber und das möchte
ich auch sagen ein historischer moment
ich nehme die fpö in schutz
das was wir nämlich gesehen haben in dem
video auch diese bereitschaft dass man
finanziert über vereine das neue jahr
und da können wir schon irgendwas machen
wenn man da macht sind dass man auch
versucht zumindest über medien sich
einfluss zu bekommen das ist ja nicht
neu das ist ja ein biotop in der
österreichischen politik dass wir über
jahrzehnte gesehen haben besonders in
dem video natürlich in einer form die
auch strafrechtlich möglicherweise
relevant ist aber dass die kultur der
intransparenz der freunderlwirtschaft
der postenvergabe anfreunden da
auftragsvergaben an freunde
da sagen wir mal etwas versteckten
parteienfinanzierung so dass wir nicht
wirklich offenlegen müssen wie es ist
kultiviert wurde und zwar zur perfektion
kultiviert wurde von sp und vp über
jahrzehnte das wissen die menschen in
unserem land auch und deshalb habe ich
klar gesagt wenn wir eine lehre daraus
ziehen dann dass diese krise eine chance
ist jetzt endlich ein für alle mal
aufzuräumen mit diesem sumpf macht macht
anfällig für machtmissbrauch und niemand
ist davor gefeit das sage ich auch das
heißt wir müssen alle miteinander dafür
sorge tragen dass es politiker gibt die
freiwillig ihre macht beschränken die
sich freiwillig einer umfangreichen
kontrolle unterwerfen und die freiwillig
den weg der größten möglichen
transparenz gehen weil nur dann können
die menschen in österreich sicher sein
dass die politikerinnen und politiker
die sie vertreten ausschließlich die
interessen dieser menschen vertreten und
niemand es sonst
ja das türkisblaue experiment ist
gescheitert
sie stehen auf dem scherbenhaufen dieses
projekts das und das ist glaube ich kein
geheimnis wir in vielerlei hinsicht aus
tiefer überzeugung abgelehnt haben ein
inhaltlicher natur personeller natur und
auch struktureller natur
wir sind nicht der meinung gewesen dass
der weg wenn sie beschritten haben über
die letzten monate der beste weg ist für
österreich es war sehr sehr viel luft
blasen sehr viel schaumschlägerei kaum
die reformen die wir wirklich ein
gemacht haben und große sorge und die
errungenschaften der liberalen
demokratie in unserem land
es war ein fehler die rechtspopulisten
an die schalthebel der macht zu lassen
ich glaube auch das hat man gesehen und
weil ich gerade vorhergesehen habe es
ist jetzt sozusagen die wieder ergreifen
da macht es war ein fehler der fpö alle
schalthebel im bereich der
sicherheitspolitik in die hand zu geben
das ist wohl wirklich jeden sonnenklar
bin allerdings auch etwas überrascht
herr kollege kickl dass die bewertung
der person sebastian kurz vom messias
zum leibhaftigen in so wenigen sekunden
vonstatten gehen kann das ist ja
wirklich ein rosenkrieg der sonderklasse
der auch sehr sehr unglaubwürdig ist
herr bundeskanzler ich bin der meinung
und sehr viele menschen in österreich
waren das über die letzten monate der
meinungen das rote linien viel früher
hätten gezogen werden müssen
rote linien erst anzuziehen wenn das
strafrecht hier hinein fährt ist zu spät
der moralische verfall findet viel
früher start oder um einen richter
dieser republik zu zitieren
nicht alles was stinkt ist
strafrechtlich relevant daher ist
unserer meinung nach auch nach diesen
auftauchen des videos klar gewesen dass
er neuwahlen kein weg vorbeiführt bis
dahin was soll passieren
meines erachtens alles dass wir das
vertrauen der menschen in die politik
wieder erlangen
und ich habe auch klar gesagt und möchte
man kann sich ja nicht aussuchen von
welcher seite lob kommt aber es ist
keine anregung gewesen und auch kein
wunsch schon eine forderung dass diese
regierung
eine verwaltungs regierung ist dass
keine wesentlichen gesetze jetzt auf den
weg gebracht werden
die nicht vielleicht noch aufschub haben
könnten bis nach der wahl
es ist im übrigen auch eine forderung an
dieses haus das wir uns selbst
verpflichten nicht wieder mit euren
wahlzuckerl im freien spiel der kräfte
sozusagen ja weit super zu geben die
haben das nie gemacht sie müssen sich an
der nase nehmen an dem sich die
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler am
ende verschlucken da habe ich auch
diesen pakt für verantwortung
vorgeschlagen dass wir denn alle
miteinander unterzeichnen weil das ist
auch verantwortungsvoll für die nächste
zeit
ich habe damit schon klar gesagt was ich
von ihnen erwarte als regierung als
kanzler und übrigens auch als fdp
parteichef
ich nehme sie beim wort wenn sie sagen
umfangreiche aufklärung und da will ich
sie auch gar nicht aus der verantwortung
lassen
da will ich ihnen als parlament ein
enges korsett geben dass wir jetzt
endlich aufräumen mit dem sumpf ich will
ihnen auch ein enges korsett geben als
vp parteichef dass sie endlich
offenlegen wer die 13 millionen
finanziert hat des nationalrats warcraft
ich will ihnen auch ein enges korsett
geben dass wir hier endlich miteinander
beschließen dass es klare
strafrechtliche sanktionen gibt bei
illegaler parteienfinanzierung und ich
will ihnen auch ein enges korsett leben
dass sie das amt des bundeskanzlers
unter ministerien die minister und
ministerinnen in den ministerien nicht
missbrauchen für wahlkampf was alles
können wir tun das parlament und das ist
unsere aufgabe als parlament und diese
aufgabe wollen wir als neos war kommen
in den nächsten monaten
sie sind eine aufforderung tun wir das
jetzt beschließen wir jetzt dass es
keine parteiwerbung mehr gibt oder
parteitaktisch gefährdet eine werbung
mehr aus dem ministerium ministern wenn
wir miteinander ausschließen wollen für
die zukunft dass sie ein bundeskanzler
nicht das parkett nutzen kann
für wahlwerbung dann wäre das ein
richtiger schritt für die zukunft im
übrigen hat man das auch in der
vergangenheit nicht gefallen und da habe
ich es auch immer wieder gesehen
ich war letzte woche klar dass ich daran
glaube dass tatsächlich jetzt verteilt
taktik keinen spielt keinen raum
einnehmen sollte es gibt in dieser
republik tendenziell zu viel taktiererei
und parteipolitische spielchen als zu
wenig was ist es glaubt was es braucht
von uns ein ist ein
verantwortungsbewusstsein für die
menschen und ein
republik die österreicherinnen und
österreicher werden im september zu wort
kommen endlagerfrage der sollte den kurs
unseres landes weiter bestimmen über die
nächsten monate erwarte ich nichts
anderes als eine verwaltungs regierung
die so sein das nötigste auf den weg
bringt aber ich erwarte mir auch dass
wir druck aufbauen dass wir endlich
diese chance nutzen zu einer neuen
politischen kultur in diesem land zu
kommen
zu einer kultur der transparenz zu einer
kultur der sauberkeit zu einer kultur
die kontrolle sucht und nicht um geht zu
einer kultur die es ausschließt dass wir
die interessen von spenderinnen und
spendern vertreten anstatt die
interessen von den österreicherinnen und
österreichern das ist unser auftrag für
die nächsten monate das ist das was wir
den menschen schuldig sind in unserem
land und das ist auch das was
bundespräsident van der bellen gemeint
hat im übrigen in richtung aller
parteien auch in richtung von evb zu
sagen dass es jetzt darum geht
verantwortung für das land zu übernehmen
damit wir sagen können so sind wir nicht
wir österreicherinnen und österreicher
so sind wir aber auch nicht als
politikerinnen und politiker vielen dank
zu wort gemeldet haben können
danke herr präsident hohes haus sehr
verehrte mitglieder der bundesregierung
der bundeskanzler
welche freude dass ich den herrn kickl
und hof auf dieser seite und nicht neben
mir zunächst einmal vorweg aber wenn man
ein anderes thema der bundeskanzler
sie haben ende jänner 2017 die zeitungen
stammen von 30 jänner 2017 meinem
geburtstag habe ich natürlich mit
besonderer aufmerksamkeit gelesen ein
regierungsprogramm unterschrieben sie
haben damals bezeugt dass sie sich an
dieses programm halten werden
sie haben sich mit dem ziel einer
gemeinsamen regierungsarbeit
verpflichtet selbst verpflichtet
ungeachtet ihrer selbstverpflichtung
haben sie dann die koalition mit der spd
aufgekündigt und so vorgezogene
neuwahlen 2017 erzwungen
ganz nüchtern betrachtet da kommt
wahrscheinlich der rechtsanwalt in mit
durch ihre unterschrift war nichts wert
sie haben ihr partner damals in die irre
geführt und vielleicht haben sind sogar
politisch betrogen
mitte dezember 2017 haben sie sich mit
der fpö obmann regierungsübereinkommen
geeinigt wiederum haben sie damit
bezeugt dass sie sich an dieses
gemeinsame programm halten werden
denn wozu unterschreibt man dem und
macht etwas aus
sie haben versprochen dass sie sich mit
dem ziel einer gemeinsamen arbeit selbst
verpflichten und ungeachtet ihrer
selbstverpflichtung haben sie dann von
nicht einmal zwei wochen die koalition
mit der fpö aufgekündigt und so erneut
vorgezogene neuwahlen 2019 oder auch
später wir werden noch sehen erzwungen
wiederum ganz nüchtern betrachtet
schon wieder bei ihrer unterschrift
nichts wert und nachdem ich einer der
wenigen wirklich konservativen hier im
haus bin muss ich ihnen sagen ein
bundeskanzler der republik österreich
dessen unterschrift ich bin in zwei
jahren zweimal als völlig wertlos
erweist der ist vertrauenswürdig er
provoziert bei wohlwollender betrachtung
entweder den verdacht generell politisch
geschäftsunfähig zu sein oder sind
bereich politischer gewerbsmäßigkeit
darauf abzusehen seinen jeweiligen
partner durch seine unterschrift
täuschen bzw betrügen zu wollen und ich
empfinde das als schändlich das
widerspricht allen vorstellungen von
treu und glauben und es ist entweder
zeugnis seines überaus zwei platten
charakters oder es ist ausdruck eines
ausschließlich auf eigene macht
erweiterung zielenden politischen
raubrittertum die von der neuen zürcher
dieses wochenende für sie gefunden die
bezeichnung eines sprengmeisters die
sachlich berechtigt diese treffende
bezeichnung zielt aber dürfte
tatsächlich kite ihres handelns lässt
man nämlich revue passieren was in den
letzten beiden jahren staatspolitisch
gemacht haben dann sind sie ein
gegenüber sich selbst unkritischer
verräter und den von ihnen selbst
eingegangenen verpflichtungen und
überzeugungen
sie haben damit den beweis erbracht dass
ihre unterschriften nichts wert sind und
sie haben gezeigt dass ihre zusagen
glaubwürdig sind
sie haben demonstriert
dass ihre bezeugten
selbstverpflichtungen nur taktische
sprossen ob ihre egozentrischen
karriereleiter sind damit das ist meine
ansicht darf ein österreichischer
bundeskanzler nicht durchkommen wenn die
rede von politischem anstand
persönlichen charakter und starts
relevanter vertragstreue für politiker
in zukunft noch irgendeine bedeutung
haben soll
aus diesen gründen stellen die
unterfertigten abgeordneten dr neue dr
bild und die weiteren abgeordneten von
jetzt den folgenden entschließungsantrag
der nationalrat heute beschließen den
bundeskanzler wird im sinne des artikel
74 absatz 1 b vg durch ausdrücklich
entschließung des nationalrates das
vertrauen versagt so das war die pflicht
jetzt wird es etwas häufig weil es
wirklich kompliziert ist
was ich von der fpö politisch halte muss
ich dem hohen haus so meine ich nicht
weiter da legen sie alle wissen es für
mich ist der vormalige fpö-chef ein
rechtsradikaler xenophobe ein politisch
genetisch seit jeher korruptions
anfälliger und deshalb mit allen
demokratisch rechtlichen mitteln zu
bekämpfen
politischer gegner aber strache und co
haben uns doch dass sie besser video die
evidenz für etwas geliefert was wir alle
und auch und gerade auch die bvb seit
jeher schon über strache und co trainers
wussten bis hinein in die abstrusen
gedankenspiele des vormals höchste
funktionärs zeigt sich hier wie besser
video eine antidemokratische realitäts
und tüchtige und auch regierungs und
tauglicher gesinnung dennoch so viel
nämlich jetzt dann zu meinem
konservativismus auch gegenüber der fpö
muss gelten was gegenüber allen anderen
gelten muss ein handschlag verpflichtet
und die vertreter der fpö maus meine ich
werde mir beipflichten dass sich selbst
ungeachtet politischer abgründe die uns
trennen stets das gespräch gesucht und
nach persönlicher verbindlichkeit
getrachtet habe und ich meine das mit
ganz pathetischer republikanischer
inbrunst
wer sich wie der herr bundeskanzler
gegenüber der fpö verpflichtet ist zur
vertragstreue
auch gegenüber der fpö verpflichtet nun
das i visa video gibt durchaus einen
sachlichen anlass von der einmal
eingegangene verpflichtung zurücktreten
zu wollen
die besonderheit der sache liegt und das
ist das holprige und etwas kompliziert
an der sache darin dass dfb nach 17 18
monaten völlig zu recht davon ausgehen
durfte dass der rücktritt von strache
und gudenus die ausreichende basis dafür
abgibt die regierungsarbeit fortzusetzen
sebastian kurz hat bei allen sogenannten
einzelfällen zwei gelegentliche nötig
gehabt seine peristaltik zu
kontrollieren
er hat aber niemals einen zweifel daran
gelassen dass er die ach so erfolgreiche
regierungsarbeit mit dieser fpö
fortsetzen will
sebastian kurz hat geschwiegen nicht
weil er sich beherrscht hat er hat
geschwiegen weil ihm diese einzelfälle
eben keine überraschung waren und weil
er immer schon darum wusste mit wem er
es zu tun hat anders gesagt kurz darf
gegenüber der fpö jetzt nicht geltend
machen was er immer schon über die fpö
wusste oder zumindest gewusst haben
musste
ich persönlich vermag dieser marken
fairness gegenüber einem demokratisch
gewählten regierungspartner auch dann
nicht die absolution zu erteilen wenn es
die fpö trifft eine partei die ich
lieber hinter dem mond als auf der
regierungsbank sehen würde
denn diese form man in der treue zu
einer freiwillig eingegangenen
verpflichtung widerspricht meines
erachtens dem höchsten gebot
zivilisierter bürgerlichkeit pacta sunt
servanda was der bundeskanzler getan hat
das zeugt davon dass er einen anlass zum
vorwand genommen hat und das zu tun was
er immer schon vor hatte auch diesen
partner wie schon zuvor die sp
hineinzulegen und abzuservieren
in meiner ersten rede hier im haus habe
ich die fpö als die größten verlierer
gekennzeichnet heute wissen sie meine
damen und herren von der fpö die mich
damals allesamt ausgelacht haben warum
ich sie so gekennzeichnet habe sie haben
sich von sebastian kurz täuschen lassen
und sich für seine egomanischen ziele
unumschränkter führerschaft
instrumentalisieren lassen
der bundeskanzler kurz noch traut das
soll ihm das vertrauen aussprechen sowie
die neos das heute machen werden ich
kann ihm nicht vertrauen und ich werde
ihn deshalb mein vertrauen versagen
danke sofort gewählt ist
[Applaus]
der antrag ist ordnungsgemäß angebracht
ausreichend unterstützt wird steht in
verhandlung
vielleicht war der nova sein ich glaube
es wird dann notwendig seien
meine damen und herren herr präsident
damen und herren der regierungsbank
kolleginnen und kollegen und vor allem
auch die zuseher hinter dem fernsehen
kollegen neuen ich glaube so faktizität
sticht anstand und zivilisation das
erleben wir gerade hier in einer
dramatischen art und weise genauso wie
wir erlebt haben so eine regierung wie
diese gab es in der zweiten republik
eigentlich noch nie dort wo wir früher
hatten frieden kooperation gemeinsam mit
ziele umgang was die zweite republik
genau ausgezeichnet hat haben wir nun
mehr konflikte unbewältigte wir haben
auseinandersetzungen
wir haben konfrontation der ultimativen
form und noch dazu dass da kann ich mir
das eine oder andere meiner worte meiner
vorredner unterstreichen nach außen hin
und das ist vor allem glaube für die
damen und herren hinter dem fernsehen
interessant nach außen hin wird hier ein
salbungsvoll des nettes gesicht gezeigt
und dahinter dort wo es eigentlich
tatsächlich hier geht findet
machtmissbrauch stattfinden ultimative
ansätzen von interessen durchsetzung die
eigentlich erschaudern lässt und das ist
das bedauerlich
das ist es bedauerlich dass das
natürlich nach dieser relativ kurzen
zeit der regierung noch nicht so richtig
heraus kommt meine damen und herren eher
kurz und es sind nicht wir die sie hier
getroffen haben sind nicht die vertreter
der opposition sondern sind die menschen
draußen auf der straße die wir vertreten
es ist ein mittelstand und es sind vor
allem auch jene die nicht zu vermögen
sind denen gegenüber sollten sie ihr
rechenschaft ablegen und das werden sie
auch im herbst machen
ich bin überzeugt davon dass das eine
oder andere war hier wirklich meine
damen und herren wir brauchen hier vorne
zu herumreden schauen wir uns doch an es
gibt das buch von mitterlehner
schauen wir uns an dieser vorgänge seien
bundeskanzler von ihm behandelt worden
ist er ist am boden gelegen und noch ist
er aufgestiegen worden auch das brauchen
sie wirklich nicht stolz sein der
bundeskanzler
genauso geht es in den anderen sie an
wir haben gutachten durchgeführt die
nicht schlicht und einfach nicht
stattgefunden haben die fristen wurden
verkürzt am parlament vorbei gearbeitet
sie haben vor lauter angst dass die
unsachlichkeit ihrer vorträge hier
erkennbar wird ja nicht einmal das
parlament einschalten wollen sondern
haben also hier jede diskussion
abgedreht und es ist natürlich etwas was
ist und das eurofighter verfahren
zunächst meine damen und herren
da hat der zuständige generalsekretär
zunächst einmal der zuständige
staatsanwalt abgezogen worden das
verfahren in eine andere staatsanwalt
überstellt worden in der anderen
staatsanwaltschaft ist dann der start
der generalsekretär aufgetreten
dort verlangt dass das verfahren
verkürzt beendet werden soll
auch ohne kenntnis des aktes worauf die
staatsanwälte damen und herren das
mündel wirklich auf der zunge zergehen
lassen
die staatsanwälte bei minister eine
anzeige eingebracht haben gegen gegen
den generalsekretär
meine damen und herren der macht das
nicht aus eigenem ja kurz erklären sie
uns bitte warum es zu tätigen absurden
vorfällen gekommen ist das ist im
rechtsstaat in der zweiten republik und
dafür auch noch nie passiert ich sagen
ja
das was sie das was sie hier von uns
verlangen das funktioniert so einfach
nicht vertrauen ist nicht etwas was es
sich verdient haben vertrauen ist nicht
etwas was sie sich erarbeitet haben sie
haben nach außen in salbungsvollen
gesprochen nach innen haben sie alles
verhindert machtpolitisch alles
durchgesetzt ohne irgendeine kooperation
die ja genau die zweite republik
ausgezeichnet hat jetzt haben sich die
die sozialpartnerschaft auch noch zu
kümmern
ja super ich glaube wir werden sie dann
wieder aufbauen weil es genau das ist
warum wir im ausland bewundert werden
genauso wie der soziale wohnbau der
sicherstellt dass wir nicht mieten haben
die sich die jungen leute nicht leisten
herr bundeskanzler herr bundeskanzler
sie werden zur kenntnis nehmen müssen
demokratie statt egomanie das ist das
was wir verlangen und das ist das was
letztlich auch zählen werden
so wortgewaltig japan der schweiz wird
der präsident der bundeskanzler
geschätzte mitglieder der
bundesregierung liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen vor allem aber wehrte
österreicherinnen und österreicher denn
sie sind an die ich mich wenden wenn sie
erwarten sich zu recht von uns dass wir
für dieses land und für österreich
arbeiten für sie arbeiten
das haben wir auch so angelegt dass
unsere angelobung im november 2017 getan
werden dass mit einer türkis blauen
koalition getan und wir haben sehr viele
dinge positiv auf den weg gebracht
werden familien entlastet werden
geringverdiener entlastet und wir haben
den klein- und mittelunternehmen endlich
wieder die wertschätzung zukommen lassen
die sie sich verdienen am freitag zu
einer woche kaufen sequenzen aus einem
video auf das nicht mehr milch sondern
sich tausende menschen in diesem land
fassungslos werden lassen und ich darf
sie schon erinnern herr kollege kickl
dass sie damals dass dieses video
aufgenommen wurde und da über verdeckte
parteispenden gesprochen wurde nennen
wir sie mal gesprochen sie
generalsekretär der sp waren sowohl für
die finanzen verantwortlich und das
einzige was wir verlangen ist die
wirkliche aufklärung nämlich eine
unabhängige aufklärung dieser vorfälle
ihre argumente uns die argumente der
opposition sind sie mich überhaupt nicht
schlüssig und auch für viele andere
österreicherinnen und österreicher nicht
denn wie erklären sie sich sonst das im
grunde genommen keiner nämlich 65
prozent sprechen sich gegen die
abberufung dieser bundesregierung und
des bundeskanzlers aus gestern ein
deutliches zeichen bei der wahl in
meinem heimatland bundesland ein
historisches wahlergebnis die övp eva
weiß die spd im burgenland klar auf
platz zwei
das ist der wählerwille meine damen und
herren
das ist mir jetzt so agiert wie sie
agiert das wundert mich jetzt nicht ich
möchte sie bitten herr kollege bild ich
glaube im moment ist er nicht dabei wenn
sie in den wahlkampf sind bitte ich sie
im namen aller österreicherinnen lassen
sie das wort meran mit ihrer person
gemeinsam kind angestellten das wäre
wirklich an absurdität nicht zu
übertreffen
davon legen hat den dreißigsten jänner
erwähnt ich nehme ihn aus dem jahr 2009
da hat die sp chefin familie
rendi-wagner dem bundeskanzler
mutlosigkeit vorgeworfen ich zitiere
hätten sie ein bisschen courage hätten
sie nicht kicker angerufen sondern
werden direkt zum bundespräsidenten
gegangen um sich die entlassung des
ministers zu bemühen misstrauensantrag
gegen titel stop kickl schilder der sp
der kollegen fand kickl als
innenminister und rang war und jetzt auf
einmal der landeshauptmann dass putin
steht auf ich zitiere es sein
politisches kalkül denn in minister zu
entlassen und er fordert seine partei
auf den kanzler zu stürzen so wie jetzt
was will denn die sp ich bin sehr
gespannt was passiert
nach der nationalratswahl in sepang war
wird sich die spd laut landeshauptmann
dosb mit seinem rot blauen kurs bewähren
oder wird es die anderen seien die die
seinerzeit schon im jahr 2017 noch in
der wahlnacht angeklopft haben bei der
fpö um eine koalition herbei zu führen
oder werden diese eingesandt
mit dieser fpö fakt ist der weg den wir
gemeinsam mit sebastian kurz
eingeschlagen haben in diesem wohnhaus
ist ein guter weg wir werden diesen weg
gemeinsam mit ihm als bundeskanzler oder
bundesparteitag mann voller hoffnung
fortsetzen denn wir wissen dass die
österreicherinnen und österreich
erkennen werden wie gut dieser weg ist
und gott sei dank ist immer zuletzt die
wählerin und der wähler am wort danke
schön
zur tatsächlichen
zur tatsächlichen berichtigung krogmann
kicken hohes haus tieferer abgeordnete
schwarz war zudem in ihrer rede
behauptet dass ich zur zeit der
aufnahmen des ibiza videos
generalsekretär der fpö gewesen wäre und
damit für die finanzen der partei
zuständig oder verantwortlich gewesen
wäre
ich bin richtige tatsächlich laut den
statuten der fpö gibt es keine finanz
zuständigkeit des generalsekretärs
vielleicht ist das in der evb anders da
müssten sie den kollegen blümel fragen
der diese funktion sehr sehr lange in
der öbb ausgeübt hat
[Applaus]
herr präsident
herr bundeskanzler geschätzte mitglieder
der bundesregierung eine sehr beliebte
und sehr erfolgreiche koalition ist zu
ende gegangen ich glaube und ich
behaupte so rasch nicht behaupte auch zu
leichtfertig es ist in dieser zeit sehr
viel gelungen es wurde die
schuldenpolitik beendet es wurden die
menschen entlastet familien unterstützt
mit dem familienbonus
arbeitslosenversicherungsbeiträge
sozialversicherungsbeiträge gesenkt
dinge sind auch offen geblieben will der
frage der erhöhung von mindestpensionen
für alle jene menschen die eine sehr
geringe pension haben aber denen es wir
verdanken dass wir in diesem land ohne
große sorgen leben dürfen im land in dem
es alles gibt was menschen brauchen eine
gute ausbildung eine intakte umwelt und
eine gesunde wirtschaft ein gutes
bildungssystem alles das verdanken wir
den generationen vor uns
die bundeswehr hat sich auch um mehr
sicherheit bemüht eine personaloffensive
damit junge polizistinnen und polizisten
in diesem wirklich spannenden beruf fuß
fassen können maßnahmen gegen die
illegale migration auch im bereich der
nachfolge von sehr alten
hubschraubermodelle beim bundesheer sei
wenn militärs aus dem ausland in
österreich zu besuch waren die alle
gesehen haben dann hat man glaubt das
sind ausstellungsstücke
ich war dann sehr verwundert dass der
menschen eingestiegen sind und
weggeflogen oder auch die nachfolge saab
105 die erst an gestanden wäre das ist
noch offen ein flugzeug 50 jahre alt
bedenken sie wenn die fahrzeuge wir vor
50 jahren die ich nicht aber welche
fahrzeuge man vor 50 jahren noch
gefahren ist offen geblieben ist auch
die frage der finanzierung des
bundesheers weil auch der
bundespräsident betont hat immer wieder
dass unser bundesheer damit es auch den
verfassungsmäßigen auftrag erfüllen kann
die nötigen finanziellen mittel benötigt
auch dieser punkt ist noch offen
geblieben
wenn ich mir mein ministerium ansehe
dann ist vieles passiert schwerpunkt
forschung dekarbonisierung autonomes
fahren die
bonner initiative um die probleme die
wir dort haben mit der verschmutzung der
ton in den griff zu bekommen
die entbürokratisierung in der luftfahrt
die 13,9 milliarden euro die in nur fünf
jahren in die schieneninfrastruktur
investiert werden
700 millionen euro personenverkehr
jährlich 100 millionen güterverkehr
offen geblieben ist mein haupt projekt
und das tut mir sehr sehr leid nämlich
die nahverkehrs milliarde beides mit
dieser nahverkehrs milliarde gelungen
wäre
auch in anderen größeren städten in
österreich die ähnliche probleme haben
wir ihn den öffentlichen verkehr massiv
zu unterstützen
und dieses projekt steht jetzt oder das
ziel den transit durch österreich teurer
zu machen ist schwieriger zu machen für
überladenen lkws die grenzen zu queren
geplant war eine automatische gewichts
messung unmittelbar nach der grenze
durchzuführen durch sensoren im boden
die technik ist vorhanden
wir hätten damit viel mehr lkw auf die
rolle auf die rollende landstrasse
gebracht es gab auch gespräche zur nova
auch bei der nova die menschen deutlich
zu entlasten
und auch die frage ob man nicht jene die
sehr alte fahrzeuge haben die die umwelt
sehr stark belasten auch finanziell
unterstützt damit sehr fahrzeuge
umsteigen können
die weniger umweltbelastend sind und
auch weniger verbrauchen und damit auch
geringere betriebskosten haben offen
geblieben ist auch ein projekt erst
gegen ende der regierungsperiode
eingeplant waren nämlich ein modell der
direkten demokratie das erstmals bürger
und bürgerinnen in der lage gewesen
wären aus eigener kraft heraus
verbindliche volksabstimmungen in die
wege zu leiten das wäre ein völlig neuer
zugang gewesen freilich konnten wir uns
in der regierung waren nicht darauf
einigen dass alles abgefragt werden kann
aber sehr ein erster schritt gewesen
ganz bestimmte dinge auch direkt aus dem
aus den aus der bewegung der bürger
heraus umsetzen zu können und damit
glaube ich dass wir dieses projekt
zu leichtfertig aufs spiel gesetzt haben
gabi schwarz feuer am rednerpult
ein blick ins burgenland auch dort hat
der övp betont nach dem video von ibiza
dessen inhalt natürlich nicht
entschuldbar ist aber ich kann aus
meiner eigenen erfahrung dass minister
sagen ich habe niemals auf bauaufträge
einfluss genommen
das käme für mich absolut nicht in frage
und das würde sie auch die öbb und die
asfinag nicht gefallen lassen
seien sie versichert wenn man der spitze
der öbb eine hervorragende
persönlichkeit und auch die asfinag ist
hervorragend geführt aber nach diesen
ereignissen hat auch der fdp wurden
gesagt keine koalition mit der fpö
die spd hat die koalition nicht
aufgekündigt
und ich behaupte es ist in einer
koalition ähnlich wie in einer
freundschaft im leben wo vielleicht ein
freund ein paar etwas tut was
unentschuldbar ist man im ersten
augenblick sagt das ist mit unserer
partnerschaft mit unserer freundschaft
nicht vereinbar
und wenn wir es dann doch schafft eine
schwierige zeit zu überstehen dann
funktionieren solche freundschaften und
partnerschaften oftmals besser als jene
die nutzen die in der krise unter waffen
das argument dass innenminister kickl
in dieser funktion nicht gegen sich
selbst ermitteln kann
trifft es deswegen nicht auf den punkt
weil in der fpö der generalsekretär
keine finanzverantwortung hat auch ich
meine damen und herren war in diesem
jahr stellvertretender
bundesparteiobmann und auch ich hatte
keine verantwortung für die finanzen und
der her da natürlich der finanzreferent
hat verantwortung für die finanzen aber
ich habe die finanzen prüfen gelassen
man kann ihnen versichern dass es keine
großspenden gegeben hat und wir werden
auch einen antrag einbringen damit es
für alle parteien künftig keine
großspenden archiv
und
wir wollen auch sicherstellen dass alles
das was ein personenkomitee ist oder
vereine geht in die wahlkampf
kostenobergrenze mit einzuberechnen ist
und zwar alle beträge
damit sich auch alle parteien daran
halten müssen
meine damen verweist noch einmal zu der
frage und zum song zum zudem gedanken
herbert kickl kann nicht gegen sich
selbst ermitteln es gibt keine
ermittlungen erstens zweitens denken wir
doch zurück an die causa innenminister
strasser
da hatten wir auch einen innenminister
der von der övp gestellt wurde und einen
justizminister der ebenfalls von der övp
gestellt wurde
und trotzdem wurde ordentlich ermittelt
und trotzdem kann man vertrauen haben in
die behörden und justiz
daher glaube ich noch einmal dass das
projekt so leichtfertig aufgegeben wurde
es war eine sehr beliebte regierung sehr
erfolgreich um sie geht damit leider zu
ende
heute steht ein misstrauensantrag auf
der tagesordnung und es ist darüber zu
befinden und abzustimmen
und ich möchte eines betonen es gibt
keine krise des staates
wir haben eine bundesverfassung die
sicherstellt dass auch in schwierigen
situationen der staat ohne staatskrise
in eine positive zukunft blicken kann
keine einzelperson keine partei alleine
kann eine staatskrise in österreich
auslösen und dafür bin ich den machern
der bundesverfassung den autoren sehr
sehr dankbar
eine regierung braucht eine mehrheit und
darum geht es heute eine regierung
braucht eine mehrheit unter diesen macht
gleichgewicht zwischen bundesregierung
bundespräsidenten und dem parlament ist
vollkommen klar dass keine regierung
arbeiten kann ohne eine mehrheit im
nationalrat auch der bundespräsident der
in diesen tagen seine aufgabe sehr
verantwortungsvoll wahrnimmt kann nicht
ohne mehrheit im parlament eine
bundesregierung ernennen
das ist unmöglich weil diese
bundesregierung schon nach kurzer zeit
wieder davon bedroht wäre dass er die
mehrheit verliert daher daher daher frau
kollegin funktioniert es nicht fällt sie
brauchen das regierung die mehrheit im
haus unbedingt sonst funktioniert es
nicht
naja darf ich den menschen den menschen
versichern bitte machen sie sich keine
sorgen
eine expertenregierung ist den regierung
aus experten und nicht was menschen die
von ihrem fach nichts verstehen wissen
dank
sobald jemand ist der abgeordnete chris
danke herr präsident herr bundeskanzler
geschätzte mitglieder der
bundesregierung meine damen und herren
ich möchte mit einem zitat beginnen und
zwar mit einem zitat von egon friedell
des großen kulturphilosophen
schriftstellers der abbau kritikers und
egon friedell hat gesagt immer ist der
vorhaben unten nur einmal ist oben im
theater gerade dort also an der sich
nach landläufiger vorstellung der
herrschaftsbereich der verstellung des
kostüms befindet sich springt der mensch
war nackter ungeschminkter hervor als
sonst irgendwo
und damit hat egon friedell gesagt dass
nicht das theater der ort der
verstellung ist sondern das sogenannte
wirkliche leben und das gebet zur video
hat es wieder mal gezeigt da war davor
haben die videokameras waren
eingeschaltet und was wir da gesehen und
gehört haben war schockierend und
demaskieren zugleich schockierend weil
man ja doch noch immer diesen alten
kinder glauben hat wenn gott ein amt
gibt dem gibt er verstand und vielleicht
auch anstand
und debattieren
da ist die maske des saubermanns die
maske des kämpfers für den kleinen mann
für die kleinen leute die maske des
patriotischen österreichers gefallen und
was ist unsere reaktion darauf
wir können sagen das ist ein einzelfall
viele menschen tun das und gehen zur
tagesordnung über das ist ein
narzisstischer höhenrausch so hat das
rheintaler genannt die sind ohnedies
zurückgetreten
ich glaube aber dass das zu kurz greift
das ibiza symptom einer politik ist die
ganz grundsätzlich fehlgeleitet ist eine
politik die bestimmt wird von misstrauen
statt vertrauen von verachtung stadt
achtung die davon bestimmt wird dass es
nicht um das gemeinwohl geht sondern um
das wohl der eigenen partei ibiza ist
ein weckruf dass diese politik ein ende
haben muss
manche hören die trompeten von jericho
und meinen dass die brüchigen fassaden
unserer politischen kultur zum einsturz
gebracht werden
ich bin ein optimistischer mensch ich
denke wir können was tun wir können die
politik verändern
wir können eine ehrliche eine saubere
eine lösungsorientierte politik nach
ehrlich ist die politik
wenn sie den menschen nichts vormacht
wenn sie nicht ängste schürt und
vorurteile befeuert sauber ist die
politik wenn man weiß wer sie finanziert
wer zahlt schafft an das nicht das
losungswort sein und lösungsorientiert
ist eine politik die versucht im
ausgleich mit anderen lösungen für die
probleme zu finden
die akzeptiert werden und die auch
nachhaltig sind für unser land notwendig
sind wir haben es jetzt in der hand die
weichen für eine solche politik zu
stellen es wir haben eine ganze menge
von anträgen eingebracht ergreifen wir
diese chance machen wir das werden wir
unsere verantwortung für dieses schöne
land gerecht wenn wir eine solche
politik machen müssen wir nicht
ängstlich darauf bedacht sein dass der
vorhang unten ist
danke
so wollte holzinger folgten ober vielen
dank herr präsident geschätzte
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger gesetzte
damen und herren auf der regierungsbank
wir sind heute mit einer eigentlich ganz
simplen frage konfrontiert und diese
lautet hat sebastian kurz unser
vertrauen verdient
trauen wir ihm zu unser land durch jene
politische krise zu führen in die uns
seine regierung gestürzt hat meinen wir
dass eine alleinregierung kurz das
verbindende vor das trennende stellt und
glauben wir dass für bundeskanzler kurz
das wohl der republik österreich vor dem
wohl der türkisen partei steht
ich habe meine berechtigten zweifeln
aber lassen sie uns gemeinsam einen
kleinen rückblick wagen mit dem mai 2017
stürzte kurz kalkuliert und eiskalt den
damaligen partei obmann und vize kanzler
dieser republik von einer art
staatspolitischen verantwortung oder
stabilität des staates schlagwörter die
heute von ihnen der bundeskanzler
mehrfach bemüht worden sind war damals
in keinster weise die rede
und diese sind damals auch nicht der
grund gewesen um sie in irgendeiner art
und weise zu bremsen weder dachten sie
damals daran die funktion des vize
kanzlers zu übernehmen noch daran die
koalition aufrecht zu erhalten
sebastian kurz wollte damals ganz nach
oben und das möglichst schnell
alles übrigens nachzulesen in einem buch
mit dem bezeichnenden titel haltung so
etwas kann dann nicht nur einer der
schmutzigsten wahlkämpfe der zweiten
republik nein
wohl auch einer der teuersten stadt
maximal sieben millionen euro
wahlkampfkosten beschränkung wurden von
der kurz övp 13 millionen euro
ausgegeben
beinahe das doppelte des gesetzlich
erlaubten mit der zu erwartenden strafe
hat man einfach kalkuliert man hat sie
einfach eingerechnet was aber ist das
anderes als vermittelter stimmenkauf und
was bedeutet das wenn personen und
parteien sich zu einer derartigen
vorgehensweise verständigen was bedeutet
das für die gesetze in diesem land die
hier gezielt von einer partei gebrochen
werden nur um sich einen eigenen vorteil
zu verschaffen
in der privatwirtschaft würde das
wettbewerbsverzerrung bedeuten und sie
sie erwarten von der bevölkerung dass
sie ein geistiges verhalten einfach
duldet aber es geht noch weiter
herr bundeskanzler herr bundeskanzler in
absoluter herrlichkeit haben sie in den
letzten eineinhalb jahren ihre
regierungsarbeit am parlament vorbei
geführt anstatt die parlamentarischen
debatten zu gehen anstatt
interessenorganisationen die
sozialpartner einzubinden anstatt
reformvorhaben auf eine breite basis zu
stellen eine breite basis des
kompromisses zu stellen haben sie mit
ihrer fraktion geschäftsordnungstricks
genutzt und debatten hier in diesem
hohen haus möglichst klein zu halten
stichwort zwölf stunden tag und dann
dann hat sebastian kurz am ende des
tages beinahe auf den tag genau
fast zwei jahre nach dem springen der
ersten regierung auch noch die zweite in
die luft gejagt nicht aber wie viele
glauben könnten weil es moralisch mit
der freiheitlichen partei nicht mehr
gehen würde sondern weil er ihre
schwäche ausnutzen wollte um sich die
alleinige macht in der koalition zu
sichern
die schlüsselressorts dieser republik
in seine hände zu bekommen und
unangenehme einblicke in schwarz türkis
netzwerke zu verunmöglichen
die freiheitlichen haben diesen plan
durchkreuzt und was wir heute sehen was
ist totale und uneingeschränkte macht
die hier vor uns sitzt und diese totale
und uneingeschränkte macht in den händen
des sprengmeisters dieser republik ja
und ganz zu guter letzt möchte ich noch
die frage aufwerfen welche rolle hat
sebastian kurz und die övp im
zusammenhang mit dem ibiza video
gespielt und wann hat er wirklich davon
erfahren wann hat bundeskanzler kurz
wirklich von diesem video erfahren wir
kennen die antworten darauf nicht aber
ein gesundes misstrauen der platte
kollegen und sie sich nicht auf kommen
sie heraus und hatten sie ihre rede ein
gesundes misstrauen gegenüber den
bundeskanzler und einer spd
alleinregierung ist allemal angebracht
vielen dank
[Applaus]
als nächster hat sich der priester
martin engelberg gemeldet bitte herr
abgeordneter sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin sehr geehrter herr
bundeskanzler wäre die mitglieder der
bundesregierung kolleginnen kollegen
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
ich mache etwas unkonventionelles ich
komme ohne vorbereitete rede hier ans
pult und leute mich von den eindrücken
und den emotionen dieser debatte ich
sage das was ich jetzt hier sagen möchte
von der position aus dass ich für mich
in anspruch nehme man immer hier an
dieser stelle gesprochen habe dass mit
dem versuch gemacht habe neutral zu sein
auch über parteigrenzen hinweg zu denken
und auch mich da raus zu sprechen und
ich wurde mitunter in meinem eigenen
klub gefragt warum ich das jetzt
eigentlich gesagt habe von dieser
position aus und nachdem ich diese
debatte sehr genau mitverfolgt habe ich
habe ihre reden wirklich in betracht
gezogen und mehr angehört die argumente
und ich sage wie der lateiner so schön
sagt sine ira et studio ihr
misstrauensantrag ist völlig ungerecht
werden
er ist
ungerechtfertigt gegenüber dem herrn
bundeskanzler der eigentlich umgekehrt
in gerade in den letzten tagen bewiesen
hat wie sehr er für dieses amt
qualifiziert ist
er ist völlig ungerechtfertigt gegenüber
den mitgliedern der bundesregierung die
bisher eine tadellose arbeit geleistet
haben und und völlig unverständlich
gegenüber den neun mitgliedern der
bundesregierung die kam ein paar tage im
amt vollkommen über jeden verdacht
erhaben bestens qualifiziert für dieses
amt sind
wie viel folgen der gedanke einen der
jüdischen liturgie gibt es unter dem
türkei wort da sind die sprüche der
väter ein ganzes kapitel das mit den
worten anfängt lakonisches man alles hat
seine zeit
ich habe in der politik lernen müssen
dass es eine zeit des zwistes des
gegenseitigen verstehens gibt der
trickserei gehört dazu ist nicht meines
aber ist wohl teil der politik es muss
aber auch eine zeit geben der
besonnenheit es muss eine zeit geben der
staatsraison es muss eine zeit geben wo
man über parteigrenzen hinweg vernunft
regieren lässt eine haltung wie es unser
bundespräsident van der bellen in
wirklich hervorragender weise in diesen
letzten tagen bewiesen hat und es
gebührt ihm wirklich nochmals größter
respekt und anerkennung für diese
halbjahr
wenn diese haltung des bundespräsidenten
noch nicht genug wäre und ich wende mich
jetzt direkt an die kolleginnen und
kollegen oder ich gehe sogar noch weiter
an die freunde der sozialdemokratie wenn
das noch nicht genug wäre dann würde ich
euch bitten zu berücksichtigen dass
jeder jeder politische kommentare in den
letzten 24 48 stunden nur kopfschütteln
für euch übrig hat und für euren
misstrauensantrag
ich glaube ihr handelt nicht im sinne
der demokratie
der republik österreich
ich glaube dass euch die geschichte und
vor allem die menschen in österreich
dafür zur rechenschaft ziehen werden
ich verhehle nicht dass ich tatsächlich
auch eine persönliche enttäuschungen
finde ich bin mit einigen von euch war
auch persönlich befreundet
alle titel meine geschichte kennen
wissen dass ich nicht in einer partei
sozusagen groß geworden bin
also es verbindet mich auch persönlich
freundschaftlich sehr viel mit einigen
kolleginnen der sozialdemokratie und ich
würde jetzt auch noch einmal diesen
appell an euch richten das noch einmal
zu überdenken aber eines ist sicher und
da möchte ich die worte auch noch einmal
des bundeskanzlers wiederholen was wie
auch immer diese abstimmung abgehe
ausgeht eines ist sicher wir stehen dazu
ist lebe die demokratie
es lebe die republik österreich
als nächsten erteile ich den herrn
abgeordneten dr nikolaus chirac das wort
bitte frau präsident und herr
bundeskanzler damit geht oder
bundesregierung ich glaube einer der
wesentlichen dinge die wir in den
letzten tagen und wochen mitbekommen
haben ist wie was für eine unfassbare
dreistigkeit am aussagen in diesen in
diesem teaser-video aufgekommen sind und
was mich noch mehr erschrocken hat und
ich glaube diese unverfrorenheit wieder
diskutiert wurde in diesem video
die hat uns alle erschrocken aber was
mich noch mehr erschrocken hat ist wie
dann die reaktionen darauf waren was wir
dort gesehen haben in dem video ist dass
der vize kanzler der republik österreich
mittlerweile ehemalige vize kanzler der
republik österreich langjähriger partei
obmann der fpö sich hinstellt und
erklärt wie man österreich gesetze
umgehen und gesetze brechen kann
und das funktioniert deswegen weil es
ein system in österreich ist das leider
gottes über jahrzehnte lang von övp spö
und fpö so eingeführt wurde dass es ein
system gibt dass es nicht nur ermöglicht
dass man die regeln so einfach und geht
sondern dass de facto auch keine
sanktionen vorsieht
und das erschrecken wir an diesen
aussagen man ja wie klar dargelegt hat
wie man das macht er mit kanzler der
teile der republik österreich verkaufen
will der öffentliche aufträge verspricht
dafür wenn es geldleistungen gibt er
sagt wie man den parteispenden mittel
mittels illegaler parteienfinanzierung
am rechnungshof vorbeischleusen kann
über irgendwelche dubiosen vereine und
ich habe nicht das gefühl dass hier
irgendjemand von övp spö und fpö ein
ernsthaftes interesse daran hat der
etwas zu ändern
ich habe dahingehend meiner meinung nach
bis jetzt viel zu wenig gehört und herr
bundeskanzler sind ja sie auch hier in
der verantwortung nicht neues
bundeskanzler sondern auch als övp
parteiobmann und wir hören immer wieder
von der vp sie sei so transparent sind
schöne ankündigungen
es ist sehr durchschaubar muss man dazu
sagen diese ankündigungen weil wenn man
sich die sache genauer anschaut dann
müssen wir ganz ganz viel nicht über die
wahlkampffinanzen die parteifinanzen der
öbb wissen bis heute nicht wo er die 13
millionen euro gekommen sind
man kann so teilen nachvollziehen aber
nicht alles wir wissen nicht wie der eu
wahlkampf finanziert finanziert wurde
wie viel budgetiert wurde dafür
ausgegeben wurde und wir kennen das ja
es ist ja nichts neues software dfb dass
man auch hier versucht über irgendwelche
vereinen konstruktionen zu schaffen
daher bundesminister brümmer der gehört
nicht da es dessen homepage wird von
einem verein betrieben
kein mensch weiß wieso dabei hat sich
ich glaube die funktionäre vor kurzem
einer tageszeitung über gesagt sie
wissen ja nicht wie es den verein gibt
und sie wehren sich das jetzt überlegen
also es ist ein system offen sie sich
das hier gemacht wurde und wir brauchen
wir denn jetzt in die eu wahlkampf
anschauen ihr kandidat walkers mandl aus
niederösterreich hat einen verein
vorzugsstimmen für lukas mandl hat jetzt
seine finanzen offen gelegt 40.000
arbeiter eingenommen sparen hat ist ein
gesetz steht ja dass man nur die 15.000
euro für seine eigene vorzugsstimmen
wahlkampagne verwenden kann alles was
drüber ist im rechenschaftsbericht der
partei ausgewiesen sein muss ich bin
sehr gespannt
ich bin sehr gespannt ob das dann auch
entsprechend plänen steht es ist ja ein
system und der bundeskanzler
das ist schön das ist dann ausweisen
aber wir erinnern uns auch noch an diese
13 millionen der generalsekretär haben
alles rausgegangen gesagt wir haben
hier das recht gebrochen und das tut uns
leid ja schön
das problem ist dass diese sanktionen so
lächerlich gering sind dass sie nach aus
der portokasse mit dem staat geld das
wir bekommen einfach drüberfahren und
das ist das hauptproblem das ist ja ein
system gibt dass sie aufgebaut haben
es ist ein system wo wir vieles noch gar
nicht wissen über welche anderen
vorhaben und organisationen über bünde
bei rheine sie sonst wohl irgendwas
finanzieren und auch gleich auf die fpö
einzugehen herr neuer bundes
parteiobmann hofer sie haben in einem
interview gesagt
auch die forderung der
rechnungshofpräsidentin für originäre
einsichtsrecht die parteifinanzen sie
gesagt nein das wollen wir nicht bei der
fpö ich sage ihnen was wenn jemand nicht
transparent ist für seinen eigenen
parteifinanzen und angst vom
rechnungshof hat dann hat er
offensichtlich was zu verstecken weil
anders erklärt sich das gar nicht wie
übrigens die app benötigt und das fand
ich fast noch beschämender ist das ibiza
video ihr ehemaliger parteiobmann und
ehemalige vize kanzler der republik
österreich hatte strache hat in einem
video gesagt dass diese gedankenspiele
keinem politiker fremd sind
diese gedankenspiele die hc strache
gehabt hat wie man österreich verkauft
wie man öffentliche aufträge als
gegenleistung für zuwendungen macht wie
man am rechnungshof vorbei bewusst das
gesetz missachtet und verletzt und
angeblich sollen diese gedankenspiele
keinem politiker frampton ich sage ihnen
was jeder vernünftige mensch in
österreich und sonst sind solche
gedankenspiele bremst und es zeigt
einiges über hc strache und auch aber
die fpö wenn solche dinge gesagt werden
ich finde das ist jetzt an der zeit ist
dass wir hundertprozentige transparenz
bei parteienfinanzen haben herr
bundeskanzler warten von ihnen als
övp-obmann auch dass sie ihre finanz
normal offenlegen ich glaube dass die
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler das
recht haben zu wissen was mit dem
steuergeld passiert ich erwarte mir von
allen hier im haus vertretenen parteien
es ist ganz logisch ist dass es echte
einsicht und prüfungsrecht des
rechnungshofes in parteienfinanzen gibt
es ist das geld der steuerzahlerinnen
und steuerzahler
und es gibt überhaupt keinen grund dass
das weiterhin im dunkeln sein soll ich
glaube wir müssen ernsthaft darüber
reden und ganz klar und das insbesondere
in richtung övp dass wir alle ford
organisationen alle vereine die im
umkreis von ihrer partei sind in die
rechenschaftsberichte hinein nehmen
das ist ja geil ist das ja in keinster
art und weise in zukunft solche dinge
noch einmal passieren können wir
brauchen einen straftatbestand illegale
parteienfinanzierung und ich glaube
wirklich dass es jetzt an der zeit ist
dass wir das endlich hinkriegen und
damit hoffentlich wieder das vertrauen
der bevölkerung in die politik zurück
bekommen
als nächstes zu wort gemeldet
abgeordneter dr peter pilz
herr bundeskanzler ich sag das besonders
deutlich herr bundeskanzler werte damen
und herren von der regierungsbank war
präsidentin wird die kolleginnen und
kollegen danke für das ahnungsvoll de
und berechtigte mehrstimmige oje oje aus
den verbänden ich werde versuchen diese
erwartung nicht zu enttäuschen
ich lese ihnen einmal vor
entschließungsantrag
diese vermischung von öffentlichen amt
und privaten interessen wie sie für
diesen fall typisch zu sein scheint ist
auch ein typisches kennzeichen freitaler
systeme einer demokratischen republik
ist das unwürdig wenn jemand nicht
bereit ist die mindest spielregeln einer
demokratischen republik zu beachten dann
bleibt uns wohl nichts anderes übrig als
ihn zum rücktritt aufzufordern
in formaler hinsicht stell ich daher
folgenden antrag entschließungsantrag
der nationalrat wolle beschließen den
bundesminister wird durch das ausdrückt
wird durch ausdrückliche entschließung
gemäß artikel 74 absatz 1
bundesverfassungsgesetz das vertrauen
versagt dieser entschließungsantrag
dieser misstrauensantrag stammt vom 18
juni 2003 das war der erste
entschließungsantrag ging das role model
von sebastian kurz gegen karl heinz
grasser der abgeordnete der diesen
entschließungsantrag eingebracht hat und
mit diesen worten erklärt hat warum man
meint dass diese minister das vertrauen
zu versagen ist heißt alexander van der
bellen und alexander van der bellen
hatte 2003 gegenüber karl heinz grasser
genau so recht wie die antragstellenden
abgeordneten der spd
und unserer liste heute gegenüber
sebastian kurz recht haben
es ist sehr selten in meinen über 30
jahren als abgeordneter habe ich nur
zweimal politiker er lebt nur zweimal
politiker in führenden
regierungsfunktionen die ein
außerordentliches talent mit einem
ausserordentlichen ehrgeiz und einer
ausserordentlichen skrupellosigkeit
verbunden haben und deren handel nur ein
ziel hatte sich selbst um niemanden
anderen das war karl heinz grasser und
das ist sebastian kurz beide beide haben
größten schaden für diese republik
angerichtet und es ist notwendig nach
karl heinz grasser auch sebastian kurz
zur verantwortung zu ziehen
es gibt einen großen unterschied
zwischen grasser und kurz bei grasser
ist das findet finanzielle interessen im
vordergrund gestanden dass sebastian
kurz gibt es ein ganz anderes als
dominierendes interesse das interesse
die gesamte macht sich und seiner partei
zu sichern
das sieht sich dass das handeln von
sebastian kurz als außenminister als
parteiobmann und jetzt als bundeskanzler
gehen wird die vorkommnisse der letzten
tage miteinander durch zuerst das ibiza
video und es lohnt sich wirklich das
ebita video im detail zu studieren weil
es uns noch lange beschäftigen wird
ich ließ ihnen vorbei darunter fast
unter wahrheitspflicht von hc strache in
kameras gesagt worden ist
ja es gibt ein paar sehr vermögen das
sie kennen alle dieser vermögenden herr
kurz ja es gibt ein paar sehr vermögende
die zahlen zwischen 500.000 und
eineinhalb bis zwei millionen
die zahlen aber nicht an die partei
sondern an einen gemeinnützigen verein
das musst du erklären verein
du musst erklären dass das nicht an den
rechnungshof geht die spende die wir
haben sind in der regel idealisten die
wollen steuersenkungen steuersenkungen
von regierungen steuersenkungen
gaston glock eis beispiel genau und so
weiter und dann rene benko der dvp und
uns zeit einer der größten immobilien
makler österreichs novo matic zahlt alle
punkt so und jetzt stellt sich eine
weitere frage warum musste auf nach
bekanntwerden dieses videos nicht was
eine selbstverständlichkeit ist
hc strache sein amt zur verfügung
stellen
herr kinos sei man tat zur verfügung
stellen sondern warum musste der
innenminister gehen
während wir in der regierung oder werden
wären ja irgend einer verantwortlichen
position gewesen wir hätten 100 gründe
gehabt dass der innenminister gehen muss
aber der bundeskanzler selbst hatte
immer wieder beteuert zwischen mich und
den innenminister kickl passt kein blatt
papier wie es in ein herz und eine seele
in der ausländerpolitik in der
einwanderungspolitik in der politik die
kleine zu verfolgen und die großen zu
schonen
das war doch da hat doch nichts zwischen
sich gepasst und plötzlich muss herbert
kickers innenminister gehen
ich hab ja nichts dagegen ich habe
persönlich nichts dagegen aber warum sie
das gemacht haben und sie das veranlasst
herr bundeskanzler das ist eine wichtige
frage sie haben damit jedenfalls eine
brücke zur freiheitlichen partei
abgebrochen und dann an sich sagt ich
mache ein expertenkabinett ich mag ein
expertenkabinett und plötzlich war das
experten und expertinnen kabinett
eine minderheitsregierung
bruno kreisky hat auch einmal eine
minderheitsregierung angeführt sein
erster weg hat ihn ins parlament geführt
und seine erste frage war die frage ans
parlament
ich stelle die vertrauensfrage
ich möchte wissen ob meine
minderheitsregierung das vertrauen des
parlaments genießt kanzler kurz
interessiert das parlament nicht er
erklärt öffentlich es ist ein unding das
ist sie am händisch der kann meine rede
kurz unterbrechen
na hoppla das gefühl nein auch auch auch
in der stunde seiner möglichen abbau
interessiert sich der bundeskanzler net
fürs parlament nicht fürs parlament
er interessiert sich für sein handy
vielleicht schreibt zudem rené behncke
droht eine sms ist okay wir hätten dann
noch eine immobilie in der mariahilfer
straße vielleicht gibt es doch einige
die dringend was vom bundeskanzler
erfahren müssen
na ja wir haben wir ja hoffentlich
erfahren wenn sich die
staatsanwaltschaft hier einiges
anschauen und dann kommt der nächste
punkt dann wird der spd signalisiert ich
mache eine hp alleinregierung ich pfeife
ich was ich rede nicht mit
sozialministerium mit einem
ausgetretenen sp-mitglied besetzen die
provokation auf die spitze treiben
dazwischen immer sind bausteine sind
bausteine sind besteht damit so richtig
wirkt und dann so die sp will nicht mit
mir
die sp vertrauten wir nicht mehr eine
riesenüberraschung und die sp nach
diesen ganzen verhüllungen vertraut
sebastian kurz nicht mehr und dann sagen
wir machen dann machen wir doch einen
misstrauensantrag weil es uns ein reicht
uns allen bis auf wenig in der vp und
hätte man geheime abstimmung würden
einige von ihnen auch gegen stefan
kooths stimmen für einige von ihnen auch
gegen sebastian kurz stimmen
bürgerpräsident sofort kann nicht der
ist diszipliniert aber andere bei denen
noch hoffnung ist so an diesem punkt war
es klar unter jetzt könnt was passieren
mit dem misstrauensantrag und braun die
nächste kurve und die nächste kurve
lothar ich hole zu mir ins
bundeskanzleramt und macht vorschläge
vorschlag eins ich sebastian kurz als
bundeskanzler gewähre das gnadenrecht es
darf in der nächsten legislaturperiode
unter
cooks ausschüsse geben gnadenrecht des
bundeskanzlers ein anderes zwei ich
sebastian kurz als bundeskanzler bin
mach keine ovp parteibuchwirtschaft bis
september fußnote nachher geht's weiter
nachher wird ungefähr und drittens ich
möchte im ministerrat nicht allein mit
meinem schwarzen freunden und feinden
gesetze und regierungsvorlagen
beschließen
ich hätte gern ein paar klubobleute der
opposition als muppets dabei denn nichts
zum reden haben nichts zum mitstimmen
haben die nur zuschauen können wie die
politik beschlossen wird die sie
zutiefst ablehnen
an dem punkt sind wir und her kurz das
begründet kein vertrauen
das ist nicht passiert sie sind nicht
zufällig hingefallen oder es hat ihnen
werden hergestellt und sie sind hin
gefallen hat dann als märtyrer wieder
aufgestanden habe kärnten dass sie
müssen im schlusssatz formulieren bitte
ganz einfacher schlusssatz lautet auch
wenn ich mit auch wenn mit der sp
misstrauensantrag in einigen punkten zu
weit geht und auch wenn ich es für einen
fehler halte das dem innenminister den
ich in jeder hinsicht sehr schätze
voreilig das misstrauen ausgesprochen
wird halte ich es trotzdem für richtig
dass dieses misstrauen von einer
möglichst großen zahl von abgeordneten
ausgesprochen wird nur dieser
misstrauensantrag und eine große
mehrheit für diesen antrag gibt uns eine
chance für mehr stabilität für ein ende
des chaos und für einen politischen
neubeginn in dieser republik dank bisher
als nächstes am wort abgeordnete diplom
ingenieurin markt bislang bitte
vielen dank frau präsidentin geschätzte
damen und herren kolleginnen kollegen
geschätzte regierungsvertreter
bundeskanzler at/presse bürgerinnen und
bürger vor den bildschirmen
vor genau 100 jahren setzte sich ein
mann namens hans kelsen an den
schreibtisch mit keinem geringeren
auftrag als unsere demokratische
bundesverfassung zu entwerfen welches
bild hatte kelsen im kopf als er sich an
die arbeit machte wovon träumt er und
gleichgesinnte damals als österreich aus
den ruinen des ersten weltkriegs
auferstand in österreich das 80 prozent
seiner landmasse verloren hatte und dem
mit der abspaltung bewegungen in kärnten
tirol salzburg und vorarlberg drohte
noch mehr verloren zu gehen
der neu gegründete des staats deutsch
österreich hatte keine überlebenschance
extremistische tendenzen in allen lagern
führten zur angespannten politischen
zeiten jedoch war der traum eines
liberalen und demokratischen österreich
präsent und dieser traum genau dieser
traum ist in dieser verfassung von 1920
aufgegangen
es war die vision einer liberalen
stabilen demokratie in der die
menschenrechte fest verankert sind eine
verfassung die unsere minderheiten
schützt und uns in den tagen der
regierungskrise halt gibt kelsen hat
ganze arbeit geleistet die verfassung
zeigt uns diese tage was sie drauf hat
sie allein die verfassung kann zwar
keinen krieg verhindern wie die
geschichte zeigt in schaden der
regierungskrise wie wir sie jetzt
erleben allerdings hält sie für jede
situation die von der norm abweicht eine
antwort parat
unser bundespräsident ist der jenige der
unser regierungsschiff momentan durch
wilde wasser navigiert allerdings tut er
das in hundertprozentiger an
jungen unsere verfassung
expertenregierung entlassung von
ministern misstrauensanträge
minderheitenregierung regierung all
diese maßnahmen beschreiben nicht im
regelfall
es sind aber die verfassungsmäßig
verankerten tools die einer stabilen
demokratie zur verfügung stehen und
deshalb liebe bürgerinnen und bürger
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen in der
politik ich möchte sie daran erinnern
dass es wichtig ist dankbar zu sein für
das was unsere vorfahren in schweren
zeiten geleistet haben
was sie geschaffen haben und wovon wir
jeden tag profitieren
die verfassung ist definitiv etwas wofür
wir jeden tag dankbar sein sollten
wir werden gerade zeuginnen und zeugen
diese tage wir uns dieser versetzte text
in wilden zeiten die republik
zusammenhält vorher zu einem jahr habe
ich am eigenen leib erfahren und gespürt
wie es sich anfühlt von der verfassung
und den darin festgeschriebenen
bestimmungen und regeln getragen zu
werden
das gibt halt und stabilität wenn sonst
überall der boden bebt und genau dieses
gefühl wünsche ich allen
österreicherinnen und österreichern
diese tage halt und stabilität
wir leben es also diese tage eine
demokratische wasserfeste verfassung die
uns durch die krise trägt was aber
braucht es zusätzlich damit es nicht
wieder zu einer derartigen krise kommt
was braucht es jetzt in der politik und
präventiv zu wirken damit wir kein bbc
2.0 erleben
hier hilft uns nämlich weder die
verfassung noch die rechtsstaatliche
gerichtsbarkeit weil im fall vom ibiza
geld nicht der rechtsbruch den
vize-kanzler zum rücktritt bewogen hat
sondern die ungeschriebenen gesetze der
politischen ethik über politische ethik
sind ganze bibliotheken geschrieben
werden wurden von der antike hand weg
wer aber bestimmt in einer demokratie
darüber was ethisch erlaubt ist
was der anstand gebietet der gesetzgeber
eben sicher nicht sicher ist allerdings
dass gerade staatliche funktionsträger
innen vorbild für
verantwortungsbewusstsein und anstand
sein sollten
und genau das braucht es meines
erachtens auch den aufstand der
anständigen ja von mir aus auch der
gutmenschen der verdammten
lasst uns über wertehaltungen moral und
ethik in der politik sprechen meine
damen und herren wäre ein vize kanzler
der mit schweren korruptionsdelikten
flirtet ein innenminister der die
rechtsextremen identität als
gleichgesinnte bezeichnet nach wie vor
möglich wenn die werte der anständigen
und guten einzug gehalten hätten in der
politik
ich glaube nicht es geht hier um werte
wie toleranz respekt achtung
verantwortung vertrauen empathie
ehrlichkeit nachhaltigkeit mut
stabilität authentizität integrität
demut bescheidenheit freundlichkeit
fröhlichkeit auch sachlichkeit wie
klingt das für sie wollen wir uns mutig
und herzhaft dafür entscheiden diese
werte in die politik zu tragen
wissen sie was dann kommt was uns dann
erwartet es erwartet uns eine ehrliche
ehrenvolle und ethische politik eine
politik die vertrauen spürt in der
bevölkerung eine politik ohne angst ohne
angst mache eine politik die angstmache
nicht mehr braucht um für wählerstimmen
zu werben weil die ethischen und hoch
anständigen politikerinnen und politiker
eine unglaubliche sogwirkung ausstrahlen
wir werden die stärker ist als angst
es erwartet uns außerdem ja vielleicht
auch so etwas wie liebe das gefühl von
zusammenhalt von zusammengehörigkeit wir
werden das menschen zusammen wachsen in
unserer wunderschönen land der vielfalt
in unseren bräuchen und traditionen
voller respekt vor dem leben der natur
indem unterschiedlichkeiten
klingt klingt das so sehr nach utopia
bevor sie mich also bis sind eine
spinnerin abkanzeln möchte ich sie daran
erinnern
im lauf der geschichte sind alle
visionäre oder die meisten visionären
vor denkerinnen als spinner bezeichnet
worden auch diejenigen die von einem
friedlichen vereinten europa der offenen
grenzen geträumt haben unter anderem
stefan zweig
daher möchte ich sie einladen ich glaube
der zeitpunkt ist jetzt perfekt es ist
die zeit gekommen gemeinsam den
wertewandel zu beschreiten
aus allen fraktionen auch aus der fpö
mein eindruck aus vier augen gesprächen
mit kolleginnen und kollegen ihrer
fraktionen zeigen mir dass die mehrheit
im raum das bedürfnis nach einer kultur
der menschlichkeit ein
aber sie sind oft in ihren kontexten
verhaftet der wertewandel wird uns
helfen unsere mitmenschen nicht länger
am aussehen oder an der kleidung sei es
das kopftuch oder bar zu bewerten
sondern am grad der menschlichkeit der
gelebten die von einer mehrheit
gewollten und gelebte menschlichkeit den
werten der menschlichkeit der neuen
politik
sie werden uns in zukunft tragen und
inhalt geben denn wir brauchen sie
werden uns regierungskrisen wie wir sie
diese tage erleben gar nicht mehr
aufkommen lassen gar nicht mehr erlauben
und damit werden wir unsere verfassung
zukünftig auch nur mehr wirklich in den
allergrößten notfällen bemühen müssen ja
sehr geschätzte kollegen wird christa
bin ich ganz bei ihnen ich bin überzeugt
wir können die politik verändern denn
schließlich und endlich geht es um
nichts weniger als darum das
angeschlagene vertrauen der menschen in
diesem land in die politik
wiederherzustellen
das ist glaube ich wohl unser
wichtigster auftrag hier herinnen vielen
dank für die aufmerksamkeit
zu wort gemeldet ist nun die frau
abgeordnete gabriele eine chance bitte
fragt ordnete vielen dank frau
präsidentin mitglieder der
bundesregierung sehr geehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen zuseherinnen und zuseher
wenn junge menschen die
demokratiewerkstatt des parlaments
besuchen dann diskutieren sie dort unter
anderem aber sicherlich über die drei
säulen die unsere demokratie ausmachen
das ist zum einen dieses parlament also
wir alle die abgeordneten dieses
wohnhauses
das ist die öffentliche verwaltung die
dann die gesetze die wir hier
beschließen exekutiert ausführt und die
vielen vielen bediensteten im
öffentlichen bereich diese gesetze
helfen umzusetzen oder direkt umsetzen
und die gerichtsbarkeit als dritte säule
die gerichtsbarkeit kontrolliert und
schaut ob wir alle jeder bürger jede
bürgerin in diesem land nach bestem
wissen und gewissen unseren diese
gesetze halten
und genau diese drei säulen oder dieses
dreieck welches nennen möchte ist sicher
in der lage in den nächsten vier monaten
bis zur wahl
auch ohne diese mitglieder der
bundesregierung die demokratie nicht
aufrecht zu erhalten sondern auch für
unser parlament für die bürgerinnen und
bürger gute arbeit zu leisten denn ich
bin vereidigt sowie sie alle auf die
verfassung und wir haben alle den eid
abgelegt nach bestem wissen und gewissen
unsere arbeit zu leisten
aber wenn zwischen anständig und
unanständig nur mehr so ein schmaler
grat ist wenn es nicht mehr anständig
ist in einer krisensituation einer
politischen krise wohl gemerkt wie wir
sie jetzt verspüren genau diese
legislative die mitglieder des
wohnhauses oder vertreterinnen dasselbe
hier zu kontaktieren und zu sagen wir
können wir alle gemeinsam diese krise
schnell bewältigen und sehen dass wir
hier den nächsten schritt tun bis zur
neuwahl wenn das nicht passiert dann ist
der schritt in die unanständigkeit nur
mehr ein sehr kleiner unter
bundeskanzler sie müssen sich gefallen
lassen dass es nicht anständig war diese
wenigen bis keinen versuche hier mit
allen vertretenen parteien so ins
gespräch zu kommen dass man diese krise
auch gemeinsam bewältigt dass sie das
verpasst um versäumt haben und wir
plädieren dafür dass wir wenn heute dem
bundeskanzler der bundesregierung und
ich möchte nicht hintanhalten zu sagen
dass die neuen mitglieder der
bundesregierung durchaus expertinnen
experten sein mögen aber es für uns aber
es für uns nicht geht ausreden lassen
für uns nicht geht dass die türkise
aufpasser aufpasserin an der seite haben
wir wollen kein wahlkampf kabinett wir
wollen ein funktionierendes kapitel der
bundeskanzler wollte sich ein wahlkampf
kabinett aufbauen das lehnen wir ab das
vertrauen ist nicht gegeben und wenn man
einander nicht mehr vertraut dann muss
man sich trennen und genau diese
trennung zu vollziehen um an den anfang
meiner worte zu kommen zu gewährleisten
dass staat handeln sichergestellt ist
dass bis zur wahl sicher und ganz ruhig
in diese wahl gegangen werden kann
deswegen ist es grund genug dieser
regierung nicht mehr zu vertragen und
ihr das vertrauen
als nächster hat sich der abgeordnete
efgani dönmez gemeldet
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin neues
präsidium sehr geehrter herr
bundeskanzler geschätzte mitglieder der
bundesregierung wehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrte medienvertreter
und zuseherinnen zu hause vor den
bildschirmen
unsere bundesverfassung unser glaube an
gleichheit und freiheit unsere
historisch robuste mittelschicht unser
großer wohlstand unser hoher
bildungsstand und unsere groß breit
aufgestellte wirtschaft all dies sollte
uns gescheit machen gegen einen
zusammenbruch der demokratie die wir
tagtäglich anderswo erleben
und trotzdem müssen wir besorgt sein
wenn führende politiker wenn auch bei
illegal und geheim gefüllten mit
gefüllten urlaubsdestinationen auch nur
in gedankenspielen andeuten wir unter
nutzung von demokratischen mitteln und
deren institutionen diese ausgehöhlt und
an günstlinge verscherbelt werden
könnten
wohin dieser weg führt erkennt man am
beispiel der ehemals säkular
laizistischen türkei solche leute
versuchen die institutionellen puffer
unserer demokratie die gerichte die
nachrichtendienste die exekutive die
aufsichtsbehörden und so weiter zu
schwächen so sehr die öffentliche
empörung über die getätigten aussagen
von den protagonisten des illegal mit
gefüllten ibiza videos berechtigt sind
so sehr sind diese artikulierten
gedankenspiele nur die spitze des
eisbergs unserer demokratischen fassade
die wahlen in österreich sind zwar frei
aber sie sind nicht fair
und viele vorrednern vorrednerin und
haben wir es auch schon angesprochen
wenn parteien um das zigfache die
wahlkampfkosten grenze überschreiten
wenn gerichte und staatsanwalt
die antikorruptionsbehörde personal
schwach abhängig und stark politisiert
sind wenn das vereinsrecht missbraucht
werden kann um konstruktionen für
indirekte wahlkampffinanzierung zu
legitimieren
oder wenn der politischen mitbewerber
und deren vereine die ihnen nahestehen
unterstellt wird dass hier geldflüsse
stattgefunden haben und diese sich dann
aber bei näherer betrachtung als unwahr
herausstellten
diese anpassung diese unkultur soll und
muss ein ende haben
wenn öffentliche aufträge im wert von
unter 100.000 euro ohne ausschreibung
und transparenz vergeben werden können
wenn politische unterstützung zu einer
beschleunigung von karrieren in justiz
exekutive und dem verwaltungsapparat
führen und persönliche freundschaften
und seilschaften personen mit mangelnder
qualifikationen in höchste ämter gehievt
werden dann reden wir hier nicht von
dschibuti land der türkei oder somalia
sondern von österreich der demokratische
rückschritte beginnt mit dem
vertrauensverlust durch handlungen
welche von politikern und parteien
gesetzt werden und endet an der wahlurne
durch die wähler denn die erosion der
demokratie geschieht so unmerklich dass
sie viele nicht wahrnehmen
wir werden im september dieses jahres
wieder zur wahlurne schreiten
unabhängig davon dass alle bisher im
parlament vertretenen parteien wieder
antreten werden muss eines als
gradmesser für uns alle herangezogen
werden wenn mit angst mit opportunismus
und feindbildern
gearbeitet wird dann ist das nicht
förderlich für unser land und auch nicht
für unsere demokratie
die nächsten wochen und monate bis zum
wahltag sollten von achtung und
zurückhaltung geprägt sein
die parteien dürfen sich nicht bis aufs
messer gegenseitig bekämpfen und dabei
die demokratie schwächen
denn aus der schwächung der demokratie
resultiert eine polarisierung und ein
erstarken der extremen diese situation
öffnet nun auch eine einzigartige
möglichkeit dass sich neue parteien mit
neuen ideen und haltungen einbringen
vielleicht gelingt es diesen einen
tatsächlichen systemwechsel
herbeizuführen und eines möchte ich zum
abschluss noch sagen sehr geehrter herr
bundeskanzler
ich werde weder ihnen noch dieser
bundesregierung das misstrauen
aussprechen denn es gehört nicht zu
meinem charakter und auch entspricht
meiner person dass sich freunden
weggefährten kollegen ehemaligen
kollegen in den rücken falle auch wenn
ich bei der erstbesten gelegenheit durch
interpretationen durch böswillige
unterstellungen wie eine heiße kartoffel
fallen lassen worden bin
in jeder demokratie stehen politiker
gelegentlich vor großen
herausforderungen sie geehrter herr
bundeskanzler und auch unser geschätzter
herr bundespräsident haben in diesen
schwierigen tagen mit ruhiger hand fünf
personen heutzutage gelegt dafür möchte
ich ihnen aufrichtig danken
ich habe
danken möchte ich auch unserem ex vize
kanzler
hier haben heinz christian strache
welcher sofort nach bekanntwerden der
causa die notwendigen konsequenzen
gezogen hat und den höchsten preis wenn
man als politiker bezahlen kann auch
bezahlt hat er hat sehr viel bösem spott
und häme auf sich gezogen
aber ich möchte dennoch hier auch meinen
dank für sein engagement für unser land
aussprechen auch wenn ich viele oder
mancher seiner inhalte und zugänge nicht
geteilt habe ich wünsche allen unseren
entscheidungsträgern unserer republik
viel kraft ein scharfes mutter es
vermögen und das wohl unseres staates
und der bürger über die eigenen partei
interessen zu stellen
danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit
als nächster hat sich der abgeordnete
josef schellhorn gemeldet bitte eine
abgeordnete danke frau präsidentin der
bundeskanzler geschätzten regierungsbank
jetzt bin ich fast am schluss also am
ende der rednerliste und ich hätte mir
wirklich gewünscht dass einer meiner
vorredner den folgenden satz sagt damit
ich ihnen nicht sagen muss vielleicht
hätte auch der herr bundeskanzler sagen
können wer heute in der früh am burgring
vorbei gefahren ist hat ein desaströses
bild gesehen und ich schäme mich für die
erneute zerstörung der bilder der
hinterbliebenen des holocaust am
burgring bitte alle um entschuldigung
und sie aber jene in verantwortung die
das in der vergangenheit toleriert sogar
gefördert haben
und das gehört abgestellt dieses
gedankengut wurde auch von dieser seite
toleriert und sie haben oft genug weg
die schon nein es reicht nicht es reicht
nicht beim raten gedicht brauche ich gar
nicht anfangen der gema wissel früher
zurück und es ist auch so aber warum
warum wollen wir sie nicht aus der
verantwortung lassen weil sie auch für
eine gewisse hygiene zuständig sein
müssten und das sollte auch in den
nächsten monaten schnellstmöglich
passieren es sollte auch
schnellstmöglich passieren dass
antworten kommen von ihnen herr
vizekanzler wie es im finanzministerium
auch und auch bei der bestellung der
casino ag parteipolitische bestellungen
und eine freunderlwirtschaft haben
einziehen lassen und das erwarte ich mir
auch noch dass sie das schnellstmöglich
beantworten unsere anfrage wie konnte es
passieren mit siedler und braun wie
konnte es so was passieren dass man so
wenig in den generalrat ifd und so wenn
in die casino ag und das sind themen der
hygiene die sie in den nächsten wochen
hoffentlich noch mit rückgrat
beantworten werden weil das gehört sich
nicht in diesem land es gehört sich
genauso nicht
in diesem land das man unter gelagerte
vereine aus ich höre jetzt nichts
karlheinz kopf dass man unter gelagerte
vereine hatte ich hier auch nichts von
der sp und von der fpö
sie alle haben unter gelagerte vereine
und sie wissen es was ihr passieren
und sie wissen die versteckte
parteienfinanzierung und ich glaube wir
müssen hier das haus grundlegend säubern
und reinigen und da braucht man nicht
nur eine besen dazu dazu sind sie alle
aufgefordert diese verantwortung zu
tragen wenn wir so eine krise haben und
wenn du was verändern willst dann
schaffe eine krise und diese krise ist
jetzt da und da appelliere ich an sia
bundeskanzler
solange es noch sind oder danach als
parteiobmann dass sie es dass sie sind
in die hand nehmen dass wir hier saubere
hände bald bekommen die einzigen die
hier saubere hände haben sind wirklich
wir vielleicht weil wir zu jung sind
aber bei uns ist alles transparent bis
zur letzten wurstsemmel machen sie sich
keine sorgen
hier gehört aufgeräumt mit ihren
parteipolitischen besetzungen mit ihren
unter gelagerten vereinen mit den
versteckten parteienförderungen danke
als nicht sehr hat sich die frage
eröffnete magistra andrea kuntzl
gemeldet bitte fragt geordnete sehr
geehrte damen und herren nur ein kleiner
nachsatz zu meinem vorredner ich
verwehre mich schon aufs schärfste
dagegen dass die neos die einzigen tier
sein sollen die saubere hände halten
haben
ich halte das geräte von alle sind
gleich und alle tun so und alle haben
schmutzige hände für extrem
demokratiepolitisch schädigend und es
ist ihnen liebe kollegen von der neos
gar nicht würdig ich würde versuchen das
zu überdenken
die
wiewohl wir einen antrag einen eigenen
antrag zur verbesserung der situation
was die spenden betrifft an vorteilen
eingebracht haben und da gesprächsbereit
sind selbstverständlich so sehr geehrte
damen und herren zum eigentlichen thema
heute ist ein bedeutender tag im
österreichischen parlament
es geht um verantwortung in
verantwortung und um vertrauen und die
sozialdemokratie die im herzen eine
staatstragende partei ist und immer war
und auch heute ist auch wenn sie das
nicht glauben sehr geehrte kolleginnen
hat sich diese entscheidung gar nicht
leicht gemacht wir haben das ausführlich
diskutiert und abgewogen und sind zu dem
schluss gekommen dass heute ein
schlusspunkt gesetzt werden soll
die frage die wir uns immer wieder
dargestellt wird die erfolgreiche
politik der letzten wochen und monaten
sehen wir anders aus unserer sicht ist
die 60 stunden woche die
verschlechterung der sozialen
absicherung von kinderreichen familien
keine erfolgreiche politik sehr geehrte
damen und herren
aber das haben wir nicht sagen das geht
man anders aber kommen wird zum
politischen thema das sie in den letzten
jahren erzeugt haben dass wie in dem
diese maßnahmen gesetzt worden sind und
das war alles andere als
vertrauensbildend der und mit dem
parlament
respektlos dialogverweigerung selbst
wenn sie die zustimmung der opposition
gebraucht haben für zwei drittel
materien haben sie keine gespräche
gesucht oder ungarn mit den ländern wohl
nur mit schwarzen landeshauptleuten
geredet wird auch wenn alle betroffen
sind die sozialpartner werden nicht
eingebunden der umgang mit den medien
stichwort organisierung insgesamt ein
bedrückendes thema das sie in den
letzten jahren hier erzeugt haben alles
andere als vertrauensbildend und dann
sehr geehrte damen und herren
dann kommt die stunde der krise die
stunde der regierungskrise man erwartet
sich sebastian kurz als
verantwortungsvollen staatsmann
auch wenn man in vielen nicht seiner
meinung ist aber was passiert schon in
der ersten erklärung in dieser situation
auf diese stunden gewartet haben sehen
wir keine spur von staatsmännisch gar
keine spur
das war eine beinharte bei kampf rede
das war dieser situation unwürdig das
wasser rolle eines österreichischen
bundeskanzlers in einer krisensituation
ungültig
was angebracht gewesen wäre in dieser
situation wäre ein ausloten mit den im
parlament vertretenen parteien zugehen
auf das parlament gewesen ausloten der
unterstützung neuwahlen
minderheitsregierung wie schauen die
mehrheitsverhältnisse aus was es gegeben
hat wenige gespräche dort nur
mitteilungen kein dialog provokationen
an die anderen parteien so sehr geehrte
damen und herren wir erwirbt man sich
vertrauen nicht so verspielt man
vertrauen und das war die vorgangsweise
der letzten wochen
es ist der versuch den wir in den
letzten tagen beobachten mussten einer
kalten machtübernahme
da versucht mit 30 31 prozent der
stimmen 100 prozent der macht zu
übernehmen das ist die wahrheit es ist
die wahrheit das unter dem titel
expertenregierung eine verdeckte övp
alleinregierung installiert werden soll
dass experten ernannt werden denen aber
ein kreis von der aufpasser zur seite
gestellt wird so dass das ganze werk in
allen ministerien bis zur wahl als
wahlkampf kabinett funktionieren soll
und das sehr geehrte damen und herren
ist nicht vertrauensbildend ganz das
gegenteil und daher lehnen wir das ab so
erwirbt man sich nicht vertrauen so
erarbeitet man sich schritt für schritt
minister die beste erzählung finde ich
dass sie sehr gehört der bundeskanzler
der garant für stabilität sein sollen
jemand der innerhalb von wenigen monaten
zwei regierungen jetzt in die luft
gesprengt hat sie sehr geehrter
bundeskanzlers ihm ganz und gar nicht
garant für stabilität
sie sind versprengt war es dass sie sind
der regierung sprengmeister republik und
daher heute
ich habe heute herr bundeskanzler
daher gilt auch für sie genug ist genug
nun hat sich der abgeordnete karl haben
wir gemeldet bitte sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin sehr geehrte mitglieder der
bundesregierung sehr geehrter
bundeskanzler hohes haus gesetzte damen
und herren es ist schon wirklich
dramatisch was in den letzten tagen
passiert ist und auch ein teil der
verlauf der sitzung zeigt diese dramatik
an mir waren überrascht über all das was
in den letzten tagen gekommen um
passiert ist aber das was wirklich
überraschend ist jetzt auch hier im
plenum ist eine neue rendi-wagner kickl
koalition in verschwörungstheorien und
anschuldigungen
wenn der herbert kickl hier draußen
steht auch vom vertrauen spricht dann
müssen wir schon darüber nachdenken das
ist eine chance gegeben hätte
diese koalition auch fortzusetzen
nämlich dann wenn die einsichtsfähigkeit
gegeben wesen also gegeben wäre gewesen
wäre muss man jetzt schon sagen dass das
was wir gesehen haben in dem video
untragbar ist dass das ein
infernalisches für die politik und das
man dann zum handeln aufgefordert ist
und nicht nur sagen kann wenn die zwei
handelnden person an die ohnehin gar
keine andere chance hatten als
zurückzutreten dann für das was sie dort
gesagt haben gab es gar keine andere
politische möglichkeit einfach dann zu
sagen es geht weiter wie bisher
das geht sich nicht aus deswegen die
frage an den koalitionspartner damals
wir müssen eine veränderung bewirkt man
den zeichen der veränderung setzen damit
wir die glaubwürdigkeit der menschen
wieder zurückholen
und was war geht herbert kickl geht die
koalition die fpö hätte eine chance
gehabt und ihr wisst gerade hier in der
fraktion der sp wieder als
generalsekretär zu dieser koalition
gestanden bin ihr hätte das in der hand
gehabt staatsräson zu zeigen aber für
herbert kickl haben eure minister die
regierung verlassen und wir haben keine
chance gehabt dann den wähler und die
wählerin im september mehr vertrauen zu
bitten das müsst ihr euch selbst
hinterfragen ob die koalition gesprengt
und dann mit verschwörungstheorien zu
argumentieren abzulenken von dem
schrecklichen was dort in dem video
gesagt worden ist herbert das
funktioniert nicht das ist auch keine
tragfähige argumentation
verschwörungstheorien die bruder nicht
sein könnten weil irgendwo kann er
irgendwas dran sein
da gibt es plötzlich doch eine achse bis
und titel in verschwörungstheorien der
beta build wiederholt schon deine
verschwörungstheorien welche allianzen
findet ja noch um jetzt diese
plenarsitzung zudem zu führen was er
vorab sind mit der regierung das
misstrauen aus
die spd stellt sich heraus und sagt auch
uns geht es um staatspolitische
verantwortung die staatspolitische
verantwortung der sp schaut er nach
chaos aus eine vorsitzende drei
meinungen wurden jan kärnten und noch
viele mehr oder ein lächeln gestern bei
einer wahlniederlage aber auch eine
unentschlossenheit rücktritt zuerst dann
doch keine neuwahlen schon mal nicht
weiß
sie führen den steelers vorsitzender des
möglichen ist aber in der frage ist mir
auch das lächeln vergangen
und dann
reden wir über verantwortung und neuen
stil damit man weiß welcher geist der
zeit in der sp umgeht darf ich ein zitat
bringen eines kommunikations referenten
der spd parteizentrale in der
löwelstraße heute ist nasse fetzen tag
jagen wir diesen versager endlich raus
und freuen wir uns des lebens das
schreibt ein kommunikations referent der
spö gerade jetzt so einen sozialen
medien der grasbahn die auch schon
aufgenommen das ist der stil der neue
stil oder der alte stil der sp auch
unter der vorsitzenden in die wagner der
es nicht staatstragend der es demokratie
gefährdend
aber
der misstrauensantrag den sie jetzt in
der rendi wagner key koalition
einbringen
der ist auch ein misstrauen gegen das
wirkliche bemühen des bundespräsidenten
stabilität und handlungsfähigkeit zu
bewahren in dieser republik ist das
bemühen des bundespräsidenten mit dem
bundeskanzler gemeinsam eine
übergangsregierung frau kollegin kunst
zu definierende ganz klar eingeschränkt
in ihren handlungsmöglichkeiten und
warum frau kollegin konnte weil das
parlament so stark ist und die regierung
keine mehrheit hat mehr in diesem haus
also zweifel sind nicht an unsere
bundesverfassung das würde auch das
beruhte
aber was wir als volkspartei und auch
der bundeskanzler immer gesagt hat auch
bei 1 gesprächen die er mit ihnen
geführt hat und das ist das was sie so
ärgert und trifft in ihrer eigenen seele
wir werden uns nicht erpressen lassen
und dann werden unsere glaubwürdigkeit
nicht aufs spiel setzen und wir werden
im september die wählerinnen und den
wähler befragen und jetzt bei dieser
letzten mal bei dieser europawahl hat
die wählerinnen und wähler dem
bundeskanzler ein ganz starkes
vertrauensvotum gegeben indem es das
beste ergebnis seiner partei bei einer
eu wahl in österreich aber wir suchen
wir suchen werden um das vertrauen der
bürgerinnen und bürger auch mit der
nationalratswahl im september und wir
werden unterwegs sind und wir werden den
dialog führen und wir werden genau darum
bitten dass wir das womit wir begonnen
haben auch fortsetzen können den
reformkurs für österreich und für dieses
land
aber gestatten sie mir auch noch eines
entsteht jetzt an ich bin seit november
2017 abgeordneter mandat dieses hauses
sowie viele meiner kolleginnen und
kollegen in den fraktionen
es ist mir und war mir eine große ehre
im land und den menschen zu dienen und
gleichzeitig auch mit dieser
bundesregierung mit dem bundeskanzler an
der spitze viel zu bewegen für dieses
land und den reformkurs zu beginnen und
die erneuerung herr bundeskanzler ich
sage dir ein herzliches danke und
gekauft für die zukunft
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
nachdem noch wortmeldungen vorliegen
fähig jetzt in der debatte weiter und es
ist eine wortmeldung des herrn
abgeordneten dr peter wittmann bitte
herr abgeordneter sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren auf der regierungsbank hohes haus
es ist eine ernste situation und dieses
misstrauen ist etwas was nicht von einer
aktion kommt dieses misstrauen ist nicht
von einer aktion ableitbar dieses
misstrauen ist über jahre entstanden
herr bundeskanzler sie waren es der den
konsens weg in österreich verlassen sie
wurden gewarnt von dieser art der
politik sie um den konsens weg verlassen
sie haben den streit mit den
sozialpartnern gesucht sie haben den
streit mit der sozialdemokratie in der
regierung gesucht ausführendes organ war
der kollege sobotka der die über
gestritten hat und damit man frauen
konnte es ist jetzt so zerstritten ich
brauche eine neue regierung
sie waren der der diesen konsens
verlassen hat jetzt haben sie den
konsens verlassen mit der freiheitlichen
partei
was immer dazu geführt aber sie haben
den konsens verlassen sie sie rufen
neuwahlen wieder aus weil sie
ausschließlich an ihre erweiterung der
macht denken ausschließlich das gibt
bezogene erweitern dann macht
ich will mehr mag die anderen sind mir
egal
ihr kollege mitterlehner hat das in dem
buch sehr vor hervorragend hervorragende
stimme gesagt im nachhinein bin ich
draufgekommen dass sie ein
machtpolitiker erster güte sind der das
risiko nicht scheut aber dieses spiel
das sie hier betreiben ist ein ganz
gefährliches spiel
und es ist ein spiel auf dem rücken
dieser republik nur ihre machtinteressen
sehnt um dieses spiel voran zu treiben
spekulativ ja ich werde schon gewinnen
und dann gehen sicher andere
konstellationen aus
diese republik ist mehrwert wie dass sie
sich für ihre spieler kämpfen
missbrauchen
das ist etwas mehr wie ich bezogene
qualität und wenn sie hier dann noch in
art eines frankreichs mit 35 prozent der
wähler unterstützung eine 100%
alleinregierung der öbb machen wollen
dann ist das fass übergelaufen weil 35
prozent nicht die mehrheit in diesem
parlament repräsentieren sondern mehr
als 50% des ring bekommen sie heute die
rechnung präsentiert weil sie ganz
einfach kann strich artig mit 35 prozent
an sap alleinregierung etablieren
wollten noch einmal hier ist das
parlament gefragt und das ist eine
aufgabe des parlaments zu bestimmen wer
die regierung bildet und nur die
mehrheit des parlaments ist hier gefragt
und das lassen sie sie ins stammbuch
geschrieben nicht die ich bezogene
selbstherrliche show des bundeskanzlers
auf mehr machtergreifung sondern er muss
hier die mehrheit bekommen und deswegen
ist es notwendig ihnen zu zeigen dass es
sich um mehrheiten bemühen müssen dass
mehrheiten mit vertrauen erarbeitet
werden und dass mehrheiten letztendlich
auf konsens beruht und nicht auf
egoistischer macht treffen
zu wort gemeldet ist nun der airport
hatte de erreichte rosenkranz
hohes haus geschätzte mitglieder der
bundesregierung warum ich heute und
jetzt noch hier herauskomme ist schon
ein es muss etwas auch zurechtgerückt
werden diese entscheidenden stunden die
sich in freitagnachmittag und samstag
unter tag sie abgespielt haben mir
persönlich tut es sehr leid weil ich im
laufe dieser gesamten bundesregierung
die sich hier gebildet hat auf der ebene
der regierung der koordinierung aber
auch hier unter den abgeordneten im
hause eine gute beziehung entwickelt
habe ja ich möchte sogar sagen eine
freundschaft ob des sebastian kurz ist
gernot blume august wöginger karl hammer
und viele andere die hier sind es war
ein ausgezeichneter weg am reformprojekt
für österreich aber was ich hier auch in
dieser nacht und ich war dabei in wietze
kanzleramt und das war bis in die frühen
morgenstunden hinein
es war die ursprüngliche sicht der dinge
dieses video war da und es war ganz klar
die beiden proponenten die beiden
schauspieler die sich dort gezeigt haben
waren rücktrittsreif und das haben sie
auch gemacht und wenn man von einem stil
der aufklärung spricht
selbstverständlich waren wir immer
willens dass alles was dort gefesselt
wurde von spenden kommen herren ich
erwähne sie gar nicht weil sie zu
unrecht hier ein bild auf der bühne her
machen würden was ihnen nicht zukommt
aber es war immer klar in dieser nacht
dass diese beiden rücktritte genügen und
dann am nächsten tag am samstag früh war
ursprünglich vom zeitplan ausgemacht 9
uhr früh eintreffen hatte strache mit
sebastian kurz das wurde abgesagt und
dann haben wir gesehen wie die schwarzen
limousinen der schwarzen
landeshauptleute ins bundeskanzleramt
gefahren sind und haben wir schon gesagt
das bedeutet jetzt wohl nichts besonders
gutes und diese und diese diskussionen
führten dann dazu dass um 11 uhr ein
gespräch mit hc strache passiert ist wo
man ihm gesagt hat ja ihr geht aber um
weiterzumachen muss herbert kickl aus
dem amt und es darf auch kein
freiheitlicher mehr das innen ressort
führen und das war etwas was in der
politik bezeichnet wird als die rote
linie was wäre denn die folge gewesen
und vielleicht war das das taktische
kalkül in der svp von beratern die dort
waren das geht in der dna der fpö nicht
weil so ein schritt vor ein schritt so
ein schritt bedeutet eines das man
nämlich den keim einer spaltungen die
fpö hinein tragen möchte das lassen wir
mit sicherheit nicht zu weil wir haben
aus dem jahr 2002
unsere lehren gezogen und darum stehen
wir auch als freiheitliche partei derart
geschlossen da was uns auch die wähler
letztlich honoriert haben auch gestern
vielleicht wird diese geschlossenheit
überraschend und wir haben auch eines
gesagt bitte wenn herbert kickl das
problem ist weil die aussage war er kann
nicht gegen sich selbst ermitteln
meine frage ist welches
ermittlungsverfahren
und wer würde denn ein
ermittlungsverfahren einleiten das
innenministerium nein mit sicherheit
nicht wenn und dazu ist auch noch
korruptionsbekämpfung im innen ressort
ist bei der staatssekretäre netz statt
das sind aber feinheiten
es gab und es gibt kein
ermittlungsverfahren gegen herbert kickl
wenn sebastian kurz gesagt hätte ich
warte jetzt darauf ob es ein
ermittlungsverfahren gegen herbert kickl
gibt dann wäre er wahrscheinlich sogar
der erste gewesen der gesagt hat ich
möchte hierbei nicht anstreifen da gehe
ich lieber selbst bevor ich mir das
antue
aber so weit sollte es gar nicht kommen
untergrund ist der herbert kickl
als innenminister der freiheitliches
programm zu 100% in dieser regierung
durchgeführt hat auch mit seiner
verordnung die mit der övp akkordiert
war wo es darum ging die asylwerber
kosten für 150 zu begrenzen nämlich dazu
zu dem was sie ohnehin vom staat
bekommen diesen symbolischen hört das
war an sich akkordiert das war noch
einer begutachtungsphase das ist bereits
am ersten tag zurückgenommen worden
obwohl wir gehört haben
es wird nichts zurückgenommen was
irgendwo in politik hinein geht
nein das sind maßnahmen die kein
vertrauen bilden und auch kein vertrauen
weiterhin jetzt so in dieser situation
sehen wir sind es in dieser situation
gezwungen unser freiheitliches lager in
zukunft auch für die republik österreich
entsprechend gut aufzustellen wir haben
weder auftrag wir sind demokratisch
legitimiert und wir bleiben es und wir
hoffen es natürlich auch stärker denn je
weil das reformprojekt für österreich
kann nur mit uns freiheitlichen
funktionieren
gerade dort werde bis man sie sind an
bord sie haben noch zwei minuten weil es
ist ihre zweite wortmeldung bitte den
linken daumen und erlauben sie mir ganz
kurz einen kommentare mein
abstimmungsverhalten mich hat der spd
antrag der misstrauens andere gegenüber
der gesamten bundesregierung gestern
nacht auch etwas kalt erwischt und
überraschendes war wenig zeit meine
meinung zu bilden
ich habe ja keinen klub keine
parteilinien der ich mich orientieren
kann
das heißt meine meinung muss ich mir
nach freiem wissen und gewissen bilden
ich habe mir jetzt eine meinung gebildet
eine positionierung ich kann ich bin
nicht bereit der gesamten
bundesregierung mein misstrauen
auszusprechen ich vertrauen und teil der
verbliebenen island ab auch der neuen
experten-minister regierung allerdings
kann ich auch nicht dagegen stimmen weil
sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler
sie haben mich in einer frage massiv
enttäuscht nämlich dem klimaschutz
der klimawandel ist die größte bedrohung
die auf die menschheit zusteuert und ich
habe von ihnen die ernsthaftigkeit
vermisst in dieser thematik und deshalb
werde ich mich werde ich mich enthalten
diese abstimmung
ich bitte um verständnis
so meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
mir liegt nun keine wortmeldung mehr vor
und damit schließe ich auch diese
debatte
und wir kommen zur abstimmung
ich werde zunächst über den
eingebrachten misstrauensantrag der
abgeordneten doktorin rendi-wagner
kolleginnen und kollegen betreffend
versagen des vertrauens gegenüber der
bundesregierung und der staatssekretärin
abstimmen lassen
ich mache jetzt auch schon darauf
aufmerksam dass sofern dieser antrag
eine mehrheit findet die abstimmung wird
den misstrauensantrag der abgeordneten
dr neu kolleginnen und kollegen
betreffen versagen des vertrauens
gegenüber den herrn bundeskanzler
entfallen wird
wir gelangen nun zur abstimmung über den
entschließungsantrag vor abgeordneten
doktorin rendi-wagner kolleginnen und
kollegen betreffend versagen des
vertrauens der bundes gegenüber der
bundesregierung unterstaatssekretäre und
gemäß artikel 74 absatz 1 in verbindung
mit der dicke ab 78 absatz 2 des
bundesverfassungsgesetzes dazu einem
solchen beschluss des nationalrates
gemäß absatz zweiter zitierten
verfassungsbestimmungen die anwesenheit
der hälfte der abgeordneten erforderlich
ist stelle ich diese auch ausdrücklich
fest
ich bitte nun jene damen und herren die
für den gegenständlichen
misstrauensantrag sich aussprechen um
ein zeichen der zustimmung
der gegenständliche antrag ist somit
angenommen
damit hat der österreichische
nationalrat der bundesregierung das
vertrauen versagt nach zustellung des
beschlusses obliegt es nun nach unserer
bundesverfassung dem herrn
bundespräsidenten eine einstweilige
bundesregierung mit der fortführung der
verwaltung zu betrauen
und ich habe ihnen arbeit das durch die
beschlussfassung damit die abstimmung
über den anderen misstrauensantrag auch
entfällt wir kommen nun mehr zur
abstimmung über den antrag des
abgeordneten neu den
verfassungsausschuss zur
berichterstattung über den antrag 773 a
der abgeordneten doktor neue kolleginnen
und kollegen betreffen
bundesverfassungsgesetz mit dem das
bundesverfassungsgesetz geändert wird
eine frist bis 11 juni zu setzen wer
spricht sich für diese fristsetzung aus
dem bitte ich auch um ein zeichen der
zustimmung
das ist mit mehrheit angenommen
es liegt mir nun es liegt mir nun ein
schriftliches verlangen von 20
abgeordneten vor
die vorgesehene fassung des amtlichen
protokolls hinsichtlich des
entschließungsantrags der abgeordneten
doktorin rendi-wagner kolleginnen und
kollegen betreffend versagen des
vertrauens gegenüber der bundesregierung
unterstaatssekretärin zu verließen damit
dieser teil mit schluss der sitzung auch
als genehmigt gilt
ich komme zum verlesen
die abgeordnete wenn die wagner
kolleginnen und kollegen bringen den
entschließungsantrag beilage c
schrägstrich 1 betreffend
misstrauensantrag gegen die
bundesregierung und die staatssekretärin
eine abstimmung der misstrauensantrag
bei leidet sie einst er wird bei
anwesenheit der verfassungsmäßig
vorgesehenen anzeigte abgeordneten
angenommen erheben sich einwendungen
gegen die fassung
oder den inhalt dieses teils des
amtlichen protokolls das ist nicht der
fall
dieser teil des amtlichen protokolls
gilt daher gemäß § 51 absatz 6 der
geschäftsordnung mit schluss dieser
sitzung als genehmigt ich gebe bekannt
dass in der heutigen sitzung die
selbstständigen anträge 827 bis 800 57a
eingebracht worden sind die nächste
sitzung des nationalrates die
geschäftsordnung mäßige mitteilungen und
zuweisungen betreffen wird berufe ich
für 16 uhr 18
das ist gleich im anschluss an diese
sitzung ein
diese sitzung ist geschlossen
nur sein
so meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
ich eröffne nun die 59 sitzung des
nationalrates die sitzung ist eröffnet
verhindert sind die abgeordneten wie in
der 78 sitzung auch bekannt gegeben
hinsichtlich der eingelangten
verhandlungsgegenstände und deren
zuweisungen verweise ich gemäß § 23
absatz 4 der geschäftsordnung auf dem
sitzungssaal verteilte mitteilung
weiters weise ich die anträge 850 852
jahren jeweils dem verfassungsausschuss
der anträge 853 jahr und 854 jahr
jeweils den gesundheitsausschuss den
alltag 855 art im ausschuss für arbeit
und soziales den alltag 856 dem
budgetausschuss und den antrag 857
jahren ausschuss für familie und jugend
zu vor eingang in die tagesordnung teile
ich auch noch mit dass der die frau
abgeordnete magistra meindl reisinger
beantragt hat den verfassungsausschuss
zur berichterstattung über den antrag 56
abgeordneten doktor in gries betreffend
parteiengesetz 212 und das geschäfts
ordnungsgesetz 1975 eine frist bis
ersten juli 2009 10 zu setzen
ferner liegt das von fünf abgeordneten
gemäß § 43 absatz 3 der geschäftsordnung
gestellte verlangen vor eine kurze
debatte über diesen fristsetzungsantrag
auch durchzuführen und diese kurze
debatte wird sogleich auch stattfinden
weil abstimmung und die abstimmung
erfolgt nach der debatte und weiter
teile ich mit dass die frau abgeordnete
magister meinen reisinger beantragt hat
den verfassungsausschuss zur
berichterstattung über die anträge 832
800 28
833 834 jahre und 835 jeweils eine frist
bis zum erster juli 2009 10 zu setzen
außerdem teile ich weiter mit dass der
herr abgeordnete dr ziemlich dem
verfassungsausschuss zur
berichterstattung über die anträge 848
und 89